Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 26. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe über die Raumfahrt im Allgemeinen und im Besonderen. In der letzten Folge haben wir mit dem ZKI auch schon einige Aspekte der Raumfahrt besprochen, die sich eben in erheblichem Maße auch wiederum unten auf der Erde auswirken. Und auch dieses Mal gehen wir ein bisschen, gehen wir nicht so weit in den Orbit hinaus, aber besprechen trotzdem einen ganz wichtigen Teil der Raumfahrt selbst. Konkret geht es um Forschen in der Schwerelosigkeit und mit einem besonderen Augenmerk auf Parabelflüge. Und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartner der 26. Ausgabe Ulrike Friedrich. Hallo, schönen guten Tag. Ja, Ihre Aufgabe beim DLR ist Projektleiterin für die Parabelflüge hier in Bonn. Ist das Teil des Raumfahrtmanagements oder ist das eine eigene Abteilung eigentlich?
Wir sind Teil des DLR Raumfahrtmanagements. Ich arbeite hier in der Abteilung, die für die Forschung in Schwerelosigkeit zuständig ist und habe da eben die Aufgabe, die Parabelflüge, die das DLR seit 1999 veranstaltet, zu organisieren.
Wie kommt man denn so in diese Position? Also was ist denn so Ihr persönlicher Hintergrund und Weg in diese Rolle?
Ja, vielleicht ein bisschen unerwartet, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich bin Biologin. Ich habe hier in Bonn Biologie studiert und habe mich da schon in meiner wissenschaftlichen Arbeit damit beschäftigt, wie Pflanzen die Schwerkraft wahrnehmen und darauf reagieren. Und wenn man mit einem solchen Thema arbeitet, dann ist auch immer gleich die Frage, ja wie kann ich denn die Schwerkraft mal wegnehmen, wie kann ich sie abschalten? Und das geht halt nur in Schwerelosigkeit und damit ist man schon in Verbindung mit der Raumfahrt, mit dem Weltraum. Und ich habe einen Teil meiner wissenschaftlichen Arbeit schon damals im Deutschen Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt durchgeführt, hatte damit auch schon Kontakt zu dem Standort hier in Köln-Bonn, habe da in einem wissenschaftlichen Institut gearbeitet und irgendwann nach der Promotion muss man natürlich mal schauen, wo geht denn so der Lebensweg hin, wo findet man nachher sein Auskommen, sein berufliches und da wurde dann eine Stelle eingerichtet im Raumfahrt- Management beim DLR, dass ich um die Lebenswissenschaften, Biologie, Medizin kümmern sollte und da habe ich auch diese Stelle dann bekommen und seitdem, das sind jetzt schon über 25 Jahre, kümmere ich mich darum, dass deutsche Wissenschaftler im Weltraum experimentieren können. Und das war am Anfang hauptsächlich große Missionen mit den Amerikanern zusammen. Wir haben Wissenschaftler, insbesondere für die Biologie war ich dann zuständig, unterstützt, die auf den Spacelab-Missionen D1 und D2 mitgeflogen sind und später dann auch andere amerikanische Shuttle-Missionen, wo wir dann jeweils hier im DLR die Geräte haben bauen lassen und die Wissenschaftler finanziell unterstützt haben und sie auch organisatorisch unterstützt haben, damit das alles klappt, dass sie im Weltraum auf solchen Missionen ihre Experimente durchführen. Das heißt zum Beispiel, wir sitzen dann im Kontrollzentrum während einer solchen Mission in den USA und haben dann Sprechfunk und beachten, dass das Experiment da termingerecht durchgeführt wird.
25 Jahre, da hat sich ja auch technologisch und wissenschaftlicher Hinsicht einiges getan. Vielleicht noch mal kurz zu dem Hintergrund mit Biologie und Pflanzen. Was war denn da eigentlich der Kick, um sich dieses Thema so speziell anzunehmen?
Ja, das ist natürlich eine wissenschaftliche Frage, die schon seit 150 Jahren von den Biologen bearbeitet wird, wo und wie können Pflanzen wahrnehmen, wie die Schwerkraftrichtung liegt. Denn wir beobachten ja draußen draußen in der Natur, dass der Spross, der Stamm eines Baumes wächst senkrecht nach oben. Und da kann man noch sagen, naja, der orientiert sich nach dem Licht, das stimmt auch zum Teil. Aber auch wenn eine Pflanze mal eine Zeit lang im Dunkeln ist, wächst sie trotzdem mit dem oberirdischen Teil nach oben und die Wurzeln wachsen senkrecht in den Boden. Und da ist es sowieso dunkel. Und da haben sich die Wissenschaftler natürlich gefragt, ja, wie macht das denn die Pflanze? Woher weiß sie das? Und natürlich hat man in bald 150 Jahren Forschung schon sehr, sehr viel herausgefunden zu diesem Thema. Aber so diese ganz detaillierten biochemischen Vorgänge, auch biophysikalischen Vorgänge, die sind immer noch nicht bekannt. Und da hat sich gerade auch in den letzten Jahrzehnten auch durch die Forschung im Weltraum sehr viel getan. Man weiß also heute mehr über Eiweißfilamente, Eiweiß, so Art Gummifäden, die da in den Zellen sind, wo schwerere Teilchen, Körnchen drin aufgehängt sind. Und man weiß auch mehr über bestimmte Kanäle, die in Membranen drinstecken, die alle mit der Wahrnehmung der Schwerkraft und dann der späteren Verarbeitung dieser Reize zu tun hat. Und das ist ein genereller Punkt in der Forschung in Schwerelosigkeit. Auf der Erde ist die Schwerkraft ja immer da. Sie hat uns von Anbeginn der Bildung der Erde begleitet. Alle physikalischen und chemischen Prozesse und natürlich auch die biologischen, also die Lebensprozesse, sind der Schwerkraft unterworfen. Und das hat sich auch alles daran angepasst, insbesondere das Leben hat sich daran angepasst. Und die Wissenschaftler heutzutage möchten natürlich auch wissen, wie sehen denn gewisse Vorgänge aus, wenn man diesen Parameter Schwerkraft mal abschalten kann. Und das ist auf der Erde eben fast nicht möglich, sondern man braucht dafür Schwerelosigkeit. Und deswegen sind wir dann hier bei diesem umfassenden Bereich der Schwerelosigkeitsforschung.
Das heißt, grundsätzlich geht es hier bei der Schwerelosigkeitsforschung nicht nur um Parabelflüge, auch wenn wir da gleich noch mal ein bisschen genauer darauf eingehen werden, sondern generell eben um die Möglichkeit, Wissenschaftler Zugang zu Schwerelosigkeit zu geben. Und da gibt es ja auch noch verschiedene andere Methoden.
Genau. Also Schwerelosigkeit ist der physikalischen Zustand freier Fall. Das heißt, jedes Objekt, das ich hier werfe, ist in einer bestimmten Phase schwerelos. Allerdings, da wir das ja nicht im Vakuum täten, ist das keine sehr gute Schwerelosigkeit. Aber ist es, ist es. Und wenn man hier vom Tisch runterspringt, dann ist man eine Drittel Sekunde schwerelos. Und springt man von einem dreistöckigen Haus runter, dann sind es schon 1,5 Sekunden. Das bekommt einen nur nicht so gut. Aber rein von der Wissenschaft her ist es Schwerelosigkeit. Und man macht auch in der Tat, so im Klassenzimmer kann man einen kleinen Fallturm bauen, der eben so Zimmerhoch ist und kriegt da auch fast eine Sekunde Schwerelosigkeit hin. Also die Bedingung ist freier Fall. Auch schiefer Wurf, das sind so die Stichworte zum Thema Schwerelosigkeit. Und nichts anderes ist auch bei Parabelflügen zum Beispiel. Das Flugzeug bewegt sich auf einer Wurfbahn und ist auch hier schwerelos. Und die Raumstation zum Beispiel, die ja um die Erde herumkreist, auch die fällt um die Erde herum, befindet sich im freien Fall. Das sind also die Bedingungen, die wir schaffen müssen, um in Schwerelosigkeit forschen zu können.
Aber es gibt auch Falltürme jetzt für die wissenschaftliche Nutzung.
Genau. Also wir müssen für die Schwerelosigkeitsforschung nicht unbedingt in den Weltraum gehen, sondern wir können eben solche Fallvorrichtungen auch auf der Erde bauen. Da gibt es zum Beispiel einen Fallturm in Bremen. Der ist 135 Meter hoch. Der hat eine Röhre im Inneren. Die kann man luftleer pumpen. Und dort kann man Experimente fallen lassen oder sogar mit einem Katapult von unten hochschießen und dann fallen sie wieder runter, sodass man bis zu neun Sekunden Schwerelosigkeit erzielen kann. Und da wird ganz viel Forschung täglich. Da werden Experimente durchgeführt, vor allen Dingen im Bereich Physik, aber auch Biologie. Aber diese Experimente können natürlich entweder automatisch ablaufen oder sie arbeiten über Fernbedienung. Aber natürlich kann kein Mensch damit fallen gelassen werden. Und neun Sekunden ist halt die begrenzte Zeit.
Und man hat wahrscheinlich auch eine Begrenzung in der Masse, die man dort fallen lassen kann bzw. katapultieren lassen kann. Was kriegt man da so hochgeschickt, ein paar Kilo?
Das sind schon über 100 Kilo, ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber die Geräte, das sind schon ordentliche wissenschaftliche Geräte, die man da zusammenbauen kann. Und auch natürlich mit elektrischer Versorgung und Datenaufzeichnung und so weiter. Also das sind schon ordentliche Experimentierbedingungen.
Aber wenn sie dann unten ankommen, dann sind sie auch kaputt?
Sie sind nicht kaputt, sondern sie landen in einem großen Auffangbehälter mit Styroporkügelchen und werden da also sanft aufgefangen und können dann auch nach ein paar Stunden wieder neu eingesetzt werden. Ja, das ist also eine solche...
Es klingt aber nach einer sehr kostengünstigen Variante von Schwerelosigkeitsforschung, der Fallturm. Oder unterschätzt man jetzt den Aufwand da?
Also der Aufwand ist auch durchaus erheblich. Man muss also eine längere Zeit lang mit sehr starken Pumpen diese Röhre evakuieren. Und natürlich ist auch das Thema Sicherheit sehr wichtig. Dafür müssen viele Vorrichtungen sein. Also das hat auch seinen Preis, aber natürlich im Vergleich zu der in Anführungsstrichen richtigen Weltraumforschung ist das dann noch eine preisgünstige Forschung.
Das Beispiel Biologie war jetzt schon sehr anschaulich. Aber auch die anderen wissenschaftlichen Disziplinen haben Schwerelosigkeitsbedarf. Was sind denn so die klassischen Bedarfe, die hier an das DLR herangetragen werden? Man muss sich ja hier bewerben. Man muss ja sagen, ich brauche Zugang zur Schwerelosigkeit. Dann muss man ja auch was auf den Tisch legen und sagen, das ist das, was ich mache. Was kommen denn da so für Anfragen?
Es ist so, dass eben Forscher aus allen möglichen verschiedenen Gebieten, Biologie, Medizin, Physik, Materialforschung, aber auch technologischen Hintergrundes, die schicken uns Experimentvorschläge. Die begutachten wir selbst, aber lassen sie auch extern von anderen Wissenschaftlern begutachten und schauen dann eben, auf welcher Flugmöglichkeit, wo Schwerelosigkeit existiert, können wir sie realisieren. Das ist zum Beispiel ein Thema, das Schmelzen und wiedererstarrn lassen von Metalllegierungen. Das ist ein schon Jahrzehnte altes Thema, das auch in der Schwerelosigkeit geforscht wird. Und zwar, wenn man Legierungen, also verschiedene Metalle in bestimmten Prozentsätzen zusammenschmelzen will, damit man zum Beispiel Motoren von Autos gießen und formen kann. Dann haben wir schon gleich ein Problem, das durch die Schwerkraft erzeugt wird. Weil nämlich, wenn ich verschiedene Metalle nehme und die zusammen mische, dann habe ich auch verschiedene schwere Teile. Das eine Metall ist schwerer als das andere. Und wenn man sie schmilzt, dann separieren die sich sofort.
Also die schweren unten und die reichen sich.
Genau, also natürlich gibt es da verschiedene Möglichkeiten, Einfluss zu nehmen. Aber diese Gießereiprozesse sind auch heute noch, beruhen sehr viel auf Erfahrung. Und man muss die natürlich auf eine mehr wissenschaftliche Basis heutzutage stellen, damit man einfach die Eigenschaften weiter verbessern und verbessern kann. Und das macht man natürlich auch wieder mit Hilfe von Computersimulationen. Aber die muss man natürlich füttern mit Daten, mit physikalischen Daten. Und dazu muss man die Eigenschaften dieser Legierungen besonders gut kennen. Und diese Eigenschaften, die misst man natürlich. Das sind also ganze Forschungsbereiche auf der Erde, die sich damit beschäftigen. Aber wie gesagt, die Schwerkraft spielt da eine Rolle. Und um mal wirklich diese Beobachtung, wenn ich flüssige Metalle habe und lasse sie jetzt erstarren, das mal ohne den störenden Einfluss der Schwerkraft zu haben, dazu muss ich in Schwerelosigkeit gehen. Und das tut man mit einem Gerät, das nennt sich Tempus. Tiegelfreies Prozessieren unter elektromagnetischer Levitation ist hiermit möglich. Das heißt, ein Tropfen einer Legierung wird in Schwebe gehalten. Und dann kann man den Erstarrungsvorgang, also vom Flüssigen zum Festwerden, dann mit verschiedenen Kameras sehr genau beobachten und daraus Werte ermitteln, womit ich dann die Computersimulationen füttern kann. Und das tut man bereits schon seit etlichen Jahren. Dieses Gerät, was in Deutschland gebaut wurde und weltweit einzigartig ist, ist schon auf verschiedenen Weltraummissionen geflogen. Und wir setzen es auch immer wieder auf Parabelflügen ein. Da kann man zwar in diesen kurzen Phasen der Schwerelosigkeit, die ja nur 22 Sekunden dauern, kann man nicht lange Erstarrungsvorgänge untersuchen, aber kurze Bereiche. Und damit kann man schon sehr interessante Werte erzielen. Daran ist zum Beispiel sogar deutsche Industrie interessiert, die dann sich auf solchen Parabelflügen mit dabei ist und dafür sogar auch bezahlt.
Na klar, weil das natürlich auch ein Riesennutzen ist.
Genau.
Denn selber können sie immer nicht ebenso die Schwerelosigkeit herstellen.
Ja, das ist so ein Beispiel. Und die Experimente auf dem Parabelflug dienen eben einmal dazu, wieder solche Werte zu bekommen. Aber andere dieser Vorgänge, andere schmelzen. Dafür braucht man dann längere Zeit. Damit geht man dann entweder auf unsere Forschungsraketen, die wir ja in Nordskandinavien regelmäßig starten, Texas heißen die. Da kann man bis zu sechs Minuten lang Schwerelosigkeit erhalten. Und auch dort werden Experimente aus Biologie, Physik und Materialforschung durchgeführt. Die werden in einer parabelförmigen Kurve Richtung Weltall geschossen und kommen dann am Fallschirm wieder zurück. Diese Experimente laufen entweder automatisch nach Zeitplan ab oder auch über Telecommand kann man von der Erde aus dort eingreifen. Und sechs Minuten, das ist dann schon eine Zeit.
Das ist ordentlich. Aber was kriegt man da für ein Payload unter in diesen Texas-Raketen?
Ja, also die haben auch so einen Durchmesser von 50-60 cm. Und da kann man eben auch wieder richtige Experimentvorrichtungen, so einen Ofen oder auch hier diese Schwebeanlage, elektromagnetische Levitationsanlage, kann man da reinbauen. Stromversorgung über Batterien ist möglich. Also so ein typisches Gerät, typische Experimentanlage, die ist so vielleicht tischhoch und hat eben wie gesagt Durchmesser 40-45 cm, 50 cm. Und davon sind dann so drei, vier übereinander gestapelt in dieser Rakete drin. Und werden dann eben dort gestartet und dann trennt sich nachher der Motor von dieser Nutzlast ab, fliegt oder schwebt, wie man sagen will, sechs Minuten lang schwerelos Richtung Orbit oder Richtung Weltraum und dann irgendwann fällt er wieder auf die Erde zurück. Dann wird ein Fallschirm geöffnet und der landet, dieser Fallschirm mit der Nutzlast dran, landet dann im Schnee irgendwo in Lapland und ein Hubschrauber fliegt dahin, gabelt es auf und bringt das wieder zum Labor zurück, zum Startpunkt. Das ist für Wissenschaftler eine sehr interessante Möglichkeit zu forschen, denn sie können noch bis zu einer Stunde vor dem Start ihre Proben, zum Beispiel biologische Proben, lebende kleine Organismen, dort reinbringen und sie kriegen sie innerhalb von einer halben, dreiviertel Stunde nach der Landung wieder zurück. Das ist sehr, sehr schnell. Das ist hands-on. Da kann man fast an der Rakete selber arbeiten, aber jedenfalls ganz in der Nähe. Das sind dann Techniker, die das in die Rakete einbauen. Das ist auch eine sehr wichtige Möglichkeit, in Schwerelosigkeit zu forschen.
Das findet häufiger statt?
Ja, so anderthalb Jahre etwa haben wir im Augenblick als Flug Frequenz. Da sind dann fünf bis sechs Experimente jeweils drauf.
Aber nur ein Flug?
Das ist ein Flug, ja.
Warum macht man das nicht häufiger? Ich würde jetzt meinen, der Bedarf ist groß genug. Da könnte man jede Woche eine hochschicken.
Das hat dann auch budgetäre Gründe. Das ist dann schon eine richtige Rakete. Das kostet dann schon einiges. Da muss man dann sehen, wie viel Geld insgesamt zur Verfügung steht. Prioritäten setzen, welche Fluggelegenheit man nutzt.
Aber die Nachfrage, da können Sie sich jetzt nicht beklagen?
Da können wir uns überhaupt nicht beklagen. Natürlich ist die Nachfrage etwas größer, als man umsetzen und realisieren kann. Aber im Großen und Ganzen können wir, glaube ich, unseren deutschen Wissenschaftlern, vom deutschen Raumfahrtprogramm her, eine gute Forschungssequenz bieten. Das heißt also, die verschiedenen Flugmöglichkeiten. Da gibt es ja dann auch noch, dass man auf Satelliten forscht und natürlich klar die Raumstation. Da ist es schon, ein regelmäßiger Zugang ist gegeben, sodass die Wissenschaftler einigermaßen gut planen können. Vor allen Dingen bei diesen kleineren Fluggelegenheiten, Fallturm, Parabelflüge, auch die Raketen. Da kann man wirklich einen Zeitplan für sich auch aufstellen, auch als Wissenschaftler. Und kann dann sicher sein, okay, in einem halben Jahr, in einem Jahr oder in zwei Jahren kriege ich das und das Ergebnis. Und bei den großen Fluggelegenheiten, so mit Satelliten und auf der Raumstation, da können allerdings schon mehrere Jahre ins Land gehen. Von dem Einreichen eines Vorschlags bis zur Realisierung.
Das ist mir jetzt gerade ein bisschen neu, dass auch auf Satelliten noch zusätzlich Schwerelosigkeitsexperimente durchgeführt werden. Ist das so die Regel? Also hat so jeder Satellit dann immer noch so ein bisschen Forschungs-Payload? Oder ist das eher so ab und zu hat man mal einen, wo das so dabei ist?
Also das sind auch spezielle Satelliten. Das sind jetzt also nicht Wettersatelliten oder Kommunikationssatelliten, sondern das sind reine Forschungssatelliten. Da arbeiten wir mit Russland schon seit vielen Jahren zusammen. Da gibt es Satelliten der sogenannten Bion- oder Photon-Serie. Die bleiben zwei bis drei Wochen im Orbit. Und die verschiedenen Experimente, auch aus verschiedenen Ländern durchaus, die werden dort dann autark mit eigener Stromversorgung an Bord. Und werden dann in diesen zwei bis drei Wochen durchgeführt. Diese Experimente laufen ebenfalls entweder automatisch ab nach vorgegebenem Zeitplan. Oder eben auch mit gewissen Telecommand-Signalen verbunden. Und hin und wieder gibt es auch Datentransfer vom Satelliten zum Boden. Und der landet dann in der sibirischen Steppe. Und die Wissenschaftler erhalten dann auch ihre Proben zurück und können die dann im Labor analysieren. Und hier können wir biologische und auch physikalische Experimente durchführen. Und das findet so Größenordnung alle zwei Jahre mal so ein Flug statt, an dem wir beteiligt sind von deutscher Seite.
Das heißt beteiligt, man gibt einen Teil der Finanzierung dazu und dann platziert man auch eine entsprechende Zahl von Experimenten.
Genau, also das ist eine bilaterale Abmachung. Und da bezahlen wir quasi für das Flugticket. Es läuft aber auch viel mit russischen Wissenschaftlern zusammen. Das sind also dann kooperative Experimente zwischen deutschen und russischen Wissenschaftlern. Und dann sind natürlich die Bedingungen auch günstiger. Man kann auch gewisse Barter-Geschäfte machen. Das heißt, wir stellen die Geräte, wir bauen die Geräte, weil da sind wir in Deutschland Spitze. Unsere Raumfahrtindustrie baut sehr, sehr gute, wissenschaftliche Geräte für den Nutzen oder für die Nutzung im Weltraum. Sowas machen wir auch bei der Nutzung der Raumstation. Also, dass man dann damit den Ticketpreis sozusagen reduzieren kann.
Genau, das ist ja eine übliche Methode, um auch mal den Geldwert klarzumachen. Da wird dann nicht mehr über konkrete Geldsummen verhandelt, sondern man sagt einfach, wir stellen den Teil der Raumstation, so wie das Columbus-Modul und andere Missionen, ATV etc.
Ganz genau, es ist ja so, dass die Raumfahrt ist einfach international, anders geht das gar nicht. Und da haben die verschiedenen Länder natürlich auch ihre Stärken, aber auch ihre Schwächen. Und wir in Deutschland haben ja zum Beispiel keinen eigenen, wirklichen Zugang zum Weltraum. Wir haben keine eigenen großen Raketen. Wir haben keine eigenen Raumstationen, sondern wir müssen das über Partner machen. Was wir aber eben, wie ich gerade sagte, exzellent haben, ist eine Industrie, die eben sehr, sehr gut solche Geräte bauen kann. Diese Expertise bringen wir einfach in das gesamte Raumfahrtgeschäft mit ein. Und davon profitieren auch unsere Wissenschaftler. Ich denke, wir können schon sagen, dass wir in Deutschland was die Vielfalt an Fluggelegenheiten, Fluggelegenheiten, sagen wir, zu den Möglichkeiten, in Schwerelosigkeit zu forschen, vom Fallturm, über Parabelflüge, über die Forschungsraketen, Satelliten und Raumstationen. Diese Vielfalt bieten wir ja unserem wissenschaftlichen Klientel dauerhaft an. Und das ist wirklich ein sehr gutes Potpourri, eine sehr gute Sammlung an Flugmöglichkeiten. Und das ist also weltweit doch ziemlich einzigartig.
Und vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen mehr Verständnis über die Vielfalt der Nutzung, auch dieses Angebot klar zu werden. Wir hatten jetzt Beispiele aus Biologie, wir hatten Beispiele aus der Materialforschung. Welche anderen, Medizin und Physik?
Also zum Beispiel bei der Physik, da sind wir dann im grundlagenwissenschaftlichen Bereich. Das heißt, es sind wissenschaftliche Fragen, die einfach für sich geklärt werden sollen. Eine solche Frage kommt zum Beispiel aus der Planetenforschung. Also irgendwann, irgendwo müssen ja Planeten mal entstehen aus irgendwelchen riesigen Staubwolken. Und diese Staubteilchen, die müssen es irgendwie mal schaffen, zusammenzukommen. Und am Anfang ist ja die Schwerkraft, weil ist ja noch sozusagen keine Masse da, wirkt sie auch noch nicht so recht. Also möchte man wissen, wie kommt das überhaupt zustande? Dass es so erste Agglomerate gibt. Und hier ist ein Forschungsthema, eben diese Zusammenstöße von solchen Staubteilchen zu untersuchen. Und weil eben am Anfang von Planetenentstehung oder Sternentstehung ja noch gar keine Schwerkraft wirksam ist, müssen diese Forschungen natürlich auch in Schwerelosigkeit stattfinden. Weil sonst kann ich das gar nicht ordentlich beobachten. Das ist also zum Beispiel so ein Grundlagenthema. Und unter anderem kann man...
Auch ein wiederkehrendes Thema.
Ein wiederkehrendes Thema, was regelmäßig zum Beispiel bei Parabelflügen mit den 22 Sekunden Schwerelosigkeit dort durchgeführt wird. Ein anderes Thema aus der Physik ist die Plasmaforschung. Plasma ist ein Aggregatzustand, wie wir ihn zum Beispiel bei Blitzen oder in Neonlampen haben. Da wird natürlich auch viel geforscht über diesen Aggregatzustand. Man hat also gefunden vor rund 20 Jahren, dass auch in diesem Aggregatzustand ein quasi kristalliner Zustand entsteht. Vor allem, wenn man dann auch noch gewisse Stäube in dieses Plasma hineinbringt, dann wirkt wiederum die Schwerkraft störend bei den reinen Beobachtungen. Auch hier ist es wichtig, dass man Forschung in Schwerelosigkeit machen kann. Das läuft jetzt auch schon jahrelang auf der Raumstation und auch ganz stetig bei Parabelflügen. Denn in den 22 Sekunden kann man zwar noch nicht sehr detailliert diese Plasmakristalle beobachten, aber man kann Ansätze schon feststellen. Und vor allen Dingen, man muss dafür ständig neue Geräte bauen, damit sie dann später auf der ISS eingesetzt werden können. Und diese Geräte immer wieder auch vorher zu testen, arbeiten die denn wirklich so, wie ich mir das vorstelle. Dafür sind zum Beispiel die Parabelflüge essentiell notwendig, weil man da eben mehrfach und mit verschiedenen Parametereingaben diese Geräte testen kann und damit nachher das wirklich absolut optimale Gerät in den Weltraum schickt, wenn es dann echt drauf ankommt.
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Man denkt ja immer so, ja, ok, dann baue ich mir mal eine Maschine und dann schauen wir uns das in eine schwere Dosigkeit an. Aber auch eine Maschine muss ja diesen Beweis, dass sie das auch wirklich tut, erst mal antreten. Und wenn man jetzt irgendwas in die ISS schickt und das funktioniert dann gar nicht, das wäre ja ein Dilemma. Das heißt, die Parabelflüge sind quasi auch Teil der technischen Entwicklung bis hin zur ISS.
Ganz genau. Also neben der reinen Forschung, wo man wirklich nur wenige Sekunden braucht, um das wissenschaftliche Ergebnis zu bekommen, wo also vielleicht Fallturme-Experimente und Parabelflug-Experimente ausreichen, um die wissenschaftliche Antwort zu geben, gibt es einen Großteil weiterer Experimente, die die Nutzung auf der Raumstation vorbereiten. Und zwar entweder, wie ich gerade andeutete, dass Experiment-Gerätschaften ausprobiert werden, damit man, man baut zwar schon 30, 40 Jahre lang solche Geräte, aber unsere Erfahrung, wie genau verhalten sich Flüssigkeiten in solchen Geräten, wie genau funktionieren sie, die sind halt doch noch immer sehr beschränkt. Und da lässt sich nicht alles genau vorhersagen, und ein solches Gerät auf die Raumstation zu bringen, ist natürlich sehr teuer und aufwendig. Die Arbeitszeit auf der Raumstation ist sehr kostbar. Und da ist es natürlich angeraten, diese Geräte vorher auszuprobieren. Und das kann man gerade auf den Parabelflügen sehr gut machen, weil da eben auch Menschen dabei sind, die diese Geräte bedienen können, die sofort reagieren können, je nachdem, wie sich diese Gerätschaft, dieses Gerät auch verhält. Sodass also dieser Aspekt Geräte technisch auszuprobieren, die dann später auf die Raumstation gehen, ist ganz wichtig. Aber diese Themen, diese Fragestellungen, die auf der Raumstation wissenschaftlich bearbeitet werden, sind natürlich sehr umfassende, sehr große Themen. Und die haben oft verschiedene Mosaiksteinchen, verschiedene Teilfragen, Aspekte. Und diese Teilaspekte kann man zum Teil eben auch auf solche Kurzzeitfluggelegenheiten, wie Parabelflug, ausprobieren, aus testen, also erforschen und kriegt dann schon Teilantworten.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen das Gerät, mit dem man selber die Experimente macht. Sind denn auch Teile der Raumstationen und Teile von anderen Raumfahrzeugen in Parabelflügen getestet worden?
Ja, das sind technologische Untersuchungen. Also wenn man zum Beispiel größere Teile von Satelliten ausprobieren will, wie sie sich in Schwerelosigkeit verhalten, dann ist auch wiederum der Parabelflug eine Möglichkeit, das zu tun. Also ein Beispiel hatten wir unlängst eine 14 Meter lange Struktur, ein sogenannter Boom, also eine rohrartige Struktur, die dann später im Weltraum ausgefahren werden soll von einem Raumkörper. Und dazwischen dann bei mehreren solcher Booms zum Beispiel eine Art Segel ausgespannt werden soll. Und das soll natürlich alles möglichst leicht sein. Und während des Starts einer solchen Struktur bis zum Weltraum muss es natürlich irgendwie eng klein verpackt sein. In diesem Fall zum Beispiel aufgerollt. Und nun soll es sich aber in Schwerelosigkeit dann doch richtig ausbreiten. Ausfahren. Ausfahren und dann auch fest als Struktur sein. Und da hat es in der Vergangenheit eben auch immer wieder Probleme gegeben bei solchen Entfaltungen von irgendwelchen Strukturen. Und da hat man zum Beispiel beim Parabelflug die gesamte Länge des Flugzeugs ausgenutzt, um diese 14 Meter lange Struktur sich ausrollen zu lassen. Wobei man dann wieder, jetzt sind wieder viele Detailfragen, wie viel Luft muss ich da reinpusten? Wie lange, damit sie sich so und so entfaltet, kann ich das stoppen zwischendurch? Also wie verhält sich dann diese Struktur?
Also Luft reinpusten, das funktioniert dann pneumatisch?
Genau, also quasi wie mit einem Föhn in dieses Rohr hineinblasen. Und dann natürlich auch die Frage, wie dick muss diese Struktur dann wirklich sein?
Aber in 22 Sekunden kriegt man doch keine 14-Meter-Struktur ausgefahren?
Ach, man bekommt, man bekommt. Das hat wunderbar geklappt.
In 22 Sekunden?
Ja. Da gibt es jetzt wunderschöne Filme drüber, die man auch auf der DLR-Webpage sich angucken kann, dass da dieser lange Boom sich entrollt, aber der klappt auch zum Teil so ein bisschen aus. Und das war also auch einfach schön anzusehen.
Aber jetzt kein, wir reden jetzt nicht von so einem Solarpaneel, weil das ist ja eigentlich eher so der Klassiker des Entfaltens.
Also hier, das ist wirklich eine rohrförmige Struktur gewesen, die ein Wissenschaft, ein Institut des DLR untersuchen wollte. Und diese Struktur von einer platten, aufgewickelten, wie so ein Feuerwehrschlauch quasi auf einer Rolle aufgewickelt, hat sich dann abgerollt, entfaltet und ist dann zu einer Röhre geworden, zu einer steifen Röhre.
Aber ein Vakuum hat das nicht gebraucht jetzt.
Na gut, das wär natürlich, sagen wir mal, das Tüpfelchen auf dem I dann noch, wenn man das auch noch hätte, weil ja auch noch die Luftreibung im Flugzeug da ist. Aber ich denke mal, diese Kräfte sind dann zu vernachlässigen gegenüber dem, was die Schwerkraft auf diesen langen Ausleger wirkt. Auf der Erde kann man sowas zum Beispiel nur machen, indem man an so eine Struktur ganz viele Helium-gefüllte Luftballons hängt, damit diese Struktur nicht sofort auf den Boden fällt, wenn man sie entfalten lässt, sondern dann horizontal hängen bleibt. Das sind natürlich nur Hilfsmittel, aber keine wirklich genaue und nachvollziehbare Entfaltung. Solche Untersuchungen, solche Tests, das sind auch Ja-Nein-Tests. Kann ich es so machen später im Weltraum? Kann ich so eine Struktur dann tatsächlich einsetzen? Dafür gibt es dann auch noch andere Beispiele, dass eben auch kleinere Strukturen, die manchmal nur zwei Meter Durchmesser haben, sich entfalten müssen, auch komplizierter entfalten müssen. Das kann man im Parabelflug dann testen. Solarpanele haben wir bisher noch nicht. Ich habe das Gefühl, es muss sich erst noch ein bisschen rumsprechen, dass man wirklich bei Parabelflügen gut solche Tests machen kann. Das ist bisher noch nicht so sehr weit verbreitet. Aber jetzt kommt doch so der ein oder andere und möchte das gerne dergleichen technisch getestet haben.
Andere Sachen, die getestet wurden, es gibt ja eigentlich eine ganze Menge lange Dinge, die ausgefahren werden müssen, die vorher zusammengeklappt haben.
Also ich weiß, dass die japanische Raumfahrtorganisation JAXA im Parabelflug tatsächlich eine größere Struktur, so aller, so nahe Panel-artig, sich entfalten lassen und hat das da geprüft. Aber bei uns auf deutscher Seite oder gar europäischer Seite ist mir das nicht bekannt.
Gibt es auch so Technologien, die jetzt ausprobiert werden, die jetzt nicht unmittelbar an Raumfahrzeugen eingesetzt werden? Also technologische Erprobungen seien jetzt auch so ein Themenfeld. Der Wissenschaftler, sind das dann alles Technologien für die Raumfahrt oder sind das auch Allerwelstechnologien?
Sind auch, ich würde nicht sagen Allerwelstechnologien, sondern es ist ja so, dass im Raumfahrtbereich generell der ist so ein Innovationstreiber. Weil man muss sich immer wieder neue Gedanken machen, wie kann ich etwas messen mit möglichst geringem Gewicht, also ein Messgerät mit sehr geringem Gewicht, möglichst klein, also miniaturisiert, möglichst leicht und auch noch einfach zu bedienen. Und diese Anforderung kommt eben aus der Raumfahrt in besonderem Maße, weil auf der Erde na gut, ist ein Gerät eben ein bisschen größer, braucht einen halben Tisch, ist ja nicht so schlimm.
Und geringe Fehleranfälligkeit.
Das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, genau. Und die Raumfahrt zwingt dazu, sich Gedanken zu machen, wie gesagt, möglichst klein, möglichst leicht, leicht zu bedienen. Und alle oder verschiedene Forscher, die im Raumfahrtbereich arbeiten und zum Beispiel für die Raumstation ein Experiment vorzubereiten, müssen sich diese Gedanken immer schon auch gleich machen. Weil wir immer sofort sagen, also hier mit diesem großen Bild, da können wir nicht in den Weltraum gehen, das muss kleiner gemacht werden. Und da arbeiten unsere Wissenschaftler und auch wir eng mit vielen deutschen Firmen zusammen, die Gerätehersteller sind. Sowas ist zum Beispiel auch wichtig im medizinischen Bereich, sodass wir da zusammenarbeiten mit Produzenten, die zum Beispiel Temperatur auf eine neue Art und Weise messen, die Temperatur, Körpertemperatur. Wie messen wir normalerweise unsere Körpertemperatur, Fieberthermometer unter die Achsel? Das ist keine genaue Messung. Im Ohr? Naja, das wird auch nur elektronisch extrapoliert. Die genaueste Messung zurzeit ist die rektale Temperaturmessung. Das ist natürlich in vielen Lebenssituationen nicht sehr angenehm. Auch bei Astronauten muss Temperatur gemessen werden, zwar die Körperinnentemperatur. Also man läuft da nicht so gern dauernd mit einem Thermometer im Porum. Und auch viele andere Menschen auf der Erde, die in besonderen Arbeitssituationen sind und wo es wichtig wäre zu wissen, was haben die denn für eine Körperinnentemperatur zum Beispiel Feuerwehrleute im Einsatz. Wenn man das also weiß, dann weiß man auch, wie groß ist die Belastung, zumindest was erhöhte Temperatur angeht. Gut, also daraus kommt...
Es gibt auch Extremsportler, Leute in Fabriken etc.
an schwierigen Arbeitsplätzen. Genau, und da kommt dann die Frage, kann man nicht auch noch auf andere Weise, ohne dass man in den Körper eindringen muss, verlässlich rückschließen auf die Körperinnentemperatur? Weil die Außentemperatur ist wieder nur ein Anzeiger, aber nicht der allein.
Die Abstrahlung ist nicht der Zustand.
Genau, und da wurde schon bereits entwickelt ein spezieller Thermosensor. Und nun gibt es aus verschiedenen Gründen da die Notwendigkeit, einen Doppelsensor draus zu machen. Und damit kann man also von außen, indem man das an den Menschen anlegt, die Körper zurückschließen auf die Körperinnentemperatur. Und das muss man natürlich auch untersuchen. Funktioniert das alles in Schwerelosigkeit? Da stellt sich auch gleich die Frage, wie verhält sich denn die Temperatur oder verändert sich die Temperatur in Schwerelosigkeit oder bei verschiedenen Beschleunigungen? Und schon haben wir so ein Gerät, was dann auch auf dem Parabelflug getestet wird. Einmal funktioniert es so, wie es funktionieren soll. Und zweitens Antworten auf wissenschaftliche Fragen.
Die Medizin spielt ja eh noch eine besondere Rolle. Ich hatte ja hier auch vor einigen Ausgaben ein Gespräch mit Herrn Gerzer über Weltraummedizin. Da kamen auch Parabelflüge schon zur Sprache, weil natürlich es nicht nur interessant ist für die medizinische Forschung, Schwerelosigkeit, ähnlich wie bei den Pflanzen, einfach herauszufinden, wie funktioniert denn eigentlich der Organismus, was passiert, wenn man jetzt die schwere Schwerkraft wegnimmt, um einfach die chemischen, biologischen Prozesse innerhalb des Körpers besser zu verstehen. Aber natürlich auch in ihrer konkreten Auswirkung auf Astronauten, gerade im Dauereinsatz auf der ISS, um einfach auch die Wirkung der Schwerelosigkeit auf den Körper besser zu verstehen. Da kamen ja so einige zur Sprache, Rückenschmerzen etc., was sich da halt üblicherweise einstellt durch die veränderten Bedingungen. Welchen Anteil haben so die medizinischen Experimente bei Parabelflügen und generell in der Spurelosigkeitsforschung?
Die Parabelflüge sind für die medizinischen Untersuchungen sehr, sehr wichtig. Denn die vorhin genannten anderen Flugmöglichkeiten, nämlich Fallturm, Satelliten, Raketen, da kann man ja keine medizinische Forschung drauf machen.
Wobei so ein Fallturm-Sprung in so Styroporkübchen wäre sicherlich auch mal ganz interessant.
Die Abbremsbeschleunigung ist dann doch erheblich. Ich glaube, die würde man nicht gut überleben. Und nun haben wir aber zum einen, wir haben Menschen im Weltraum und das wird auch so weiter in Zukunft sein. Also haben wir auch die Verantwortung, um sich um ihre Gesundheit und Gesunderhaltung und Fitnesserhaltung zu kümmern. Und die einzige Möglichkeit, außer eben direkt auf die Raumstation zu gehen und da zu forschen, sind eben diese Parabelflüge. Nun haben wir da ja nur Phasen von 22 Sekunden Schwerelosigkeit. Da würde man jetzt denken, ja was passiert denn mit Menschen schon in 22 Sekunden? Aber man wird es kaum glauben, da passiert unheimlich viel. Das heißt, die Parabelflüge sind eine sehr gute Möglichkeit, in verschiedenen Themen der humanphysiologischen Forschung zu arbeiten. Ein Thema ist zum Beispiel die Verlagerung von Flüssigkeiten im Menschen bei verschiedenen Beschleunigungen. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, bei Parabelflügen haben wir im normalen Flug natürlich die Wirkung der Schwerkraft, ganz klar. Dann haben wir die Phasen der Schwerelosigkeit. Die sind eben immer 22 Sekunden. Aber davor und danach haben wir ja noch fast die doppelte Erdbeschleunigung, die durch das Schwungholen und Abbremsen sozusagen dieser Parabel wirken. Und so dass viele Wissenschaftler nicht nur Schwerelosigkeit untersuchen, sondern auch noch diese verschiedenen Wechsel und die Phasen dieser doppelten Beschleunigung. Und man weiß also von den Astronauten im Weltraum, dass da eine Flüssigkeitsverschiebung vom unteren Teil des Körpers in den oberen Teil stattfindet. Also Blut, aber auch übrige Körperflüssigkeit. Das führt dann zu sogenannten Puffy Face, also so ein geschwollenes Gesicht. Und zu den Storchenbeinen, also recht dünne Beine. Und das hat natürlich in der Physiologie des Körpers, auch in der Regulierung des ganzen Flüssigkeitshaushalts, bis zum Herzschlag hin, hat das natürlich Auswirkungen. Und nun hat man erst gedacht, naja, es kommt eben, weil die da ja Tage, Wochen, Monate lang im Weltraum sind. Hat das zwar auch schon ziemlich schnell beobachtet, dass es auftritt, aber die Parabelflüge haben gezeigt, dass das innerhalb von Sekunden bereits zu dieser starken Flüssigkeitsverschiebung im Körper kommt. Mit all den Nachfolgen, also auch natürlich gewisse Temperaturveränderungen dann, und die Hautdicke verändert sich und so weiter und so fort. Und insofern kann man bei den Parabelflügen die schnellen Wechsel bereits sehr gut untersuchen. Nun kann man natürlich sagen, ja, das ist dann ja eine Forschung, die sehr stark auf Raumfahrt, auf die Astronauten ausgerichtet ist. Das ist auch richtig. Wie gesagt, wir haben die Verantwortung, Astronauten gesund zu erhalten. Wir müssen uns um ihr Wohlergehen kümmern. Aber diese ganze Forschung, die dann dahinter steht, beinhaltet sehr, sehr viele Themen, die eben auch auf der Erde von Bedeutung sind. Zum Beispiel Thema Udämbildung, also Wassereinlagerungen ins Gewebe, sind nicht 100% verstanden auf der Erde. Und auch viele Behandlungen von solchen Problemen wie Udämen, das hat auch wieder mit Blutdruck, ist da auch wieder ein Thema, die werden natürlich die Ärzte behandeln. Und da gibt es viele Medikamente. Aber in vielen Bereichen ist die wirkliche Grund, und wie das alles reguliert wird, ist eben noch nicht richtig bekannt. Und die Möglichkeiten, die die Forschung in Schwerelosigkeit dazu bietet, sind ein Add-on, also eine weitere Möglichkeit, hier im Detail tiefer zu forschen. Und neben der terrestrischen Forschung interessante Teilaspekte dort herauszubekommen. Dieses Thema Flüssigkeitsverschiebung ist so etwas, aber natürlich auch unser Gleichgewichtssinn, der dazu führt, dass wir auf der Erde wissen, wenn wir gesund sind, wo oben und wo unten ist. Wie so ganz genau der funktioniert, ist wiederum noch nicht 100 Prozent geklärt. Da wird im Weltraum und eben auch bei Parabelflügen mit Modellsystemen gearbeitet. Man arbeitet am Menschen auch, untersucht den. Aber wir müssen da auch manchmal in das Gleichgewichtsorgan wirklich reingucken. Das würden die Menschen nicht so gerne haben, dass wir ihnen da die schönen Gehörsteinchen rausnehmen und da was nachschauen. Dazu nutzen die Wissenschaftler Modellsysteme, zum Beispiel Fische. Fische haben auch rechts und links ein Gleichgewichtsorgan, wie wir Menschen. Sie haben kleine Steinchen, die auf Härchen liegen, die dann für diese Wahrnehmung der Schwerkraftrichtung zuständig sind. Da laufen dann zum Beispiel solche Untersuchungen, auch bei Parabelflügen, wo man schaut, wieso wird der eine Fisch, reagiert der so und der andere so? Und warum wird dem einen Fisch schlecht und dem anderen nicht? Das geht dann auch so in Richtung Raumkrankheit-Untersuchungen hier zu.
Wie merkt man denn, ob dem Fisch schlecht wird?
Auch Fische können sich übergeben.
Das bringt uns jetzt alles sehr auf den Parabelflug, in dem wir jetzt schon so einige Parabeln herumgeflogen sind. Ich hatte ja auch selbst vor einiger Zeit die Gelegenheit, am 18. Parabelflug des DLR teilzunehmen. Interessante Erfahrung. Warum wir den jetzt brauchen, denke ich, das ist jetzt schon ganz gut klar geworden. Jetzt ist das natürlich eine erhebliche organisatorische Leistung, die da gebracht werden muss. Das ist mir so als Teilnehmer schnell klar geworden. Sehr viele Leute fliegen damit. Ich glaube, es waren so 40 Leute. Wissenschaftler, Crew-Mitglieder etc. Begleiter aller Art, die Piloten natürlich. Das Ganze braucht sicherlich eine erhebliche technische Vorbereitung. Wie läuft denn das alles ab? Vielleicht zunächst einmal dieses Flugzeug. Es ist jetzt auch nicht irgendein Flugzeug, sondern es ist schon ein speziell für diesen Einsatz präpariertes Gerät. Was war das, ein Airbus?
Ein Airbus A300, einer der ersten dieser ganzen Serie 300. Er ist 1973 zum ersten Mal geflogen, hatte seinen Jungfernflug. Er ist der älteste Airbus 300, der heute überhaupt noch fliegt. Es ist ein Experimentalflugzeug, ist also niemals als Passagierflugzeug oder Cargoflugzeug geflogen, sondern immer nur im Einsatz für technische Erprobungen und jetzt eben seit Mitte der 90er Jahre als Flugzeug für Parabelflüge.
Also vorher ist es bei Airbus für technische Erprobungen verwendet worden.
Und dieses Flugzeug brauchte gar nicht so arg viel verändert zu werden, weil das ein sehr stabiles, ein sehr starkes Flugzeug ist, mit sehr kräftigen Turbinen, die also genügend Schub für diese...
Der A300 generell oder dieser spezielle A300?
Nein, der A300 generell, weil dieses Flugzeug ist so, wie A300s generell auch sind. Ist eben damals als erstes Erprobungsflugzeug, als drittes Flugzeug. Das erste ist niemals geflogen, das war nur für den Boden. Das zweite Testflugzeug ist geflogen, aber schon lange in Ruhestand. Und das dritte Testflugzeug ist eben unser Airbus. Und man würde jetzt vielleicht denken, Gottes Willen, 1973 Jungfernflug und damit fliegt ihr solche Manöver. Da muss man sagen, ein Flugzeug wird nicht alt, oder weniger jedenfalls durch die Jahre, sondern durch die Anzahl der Flugstunden und vor allen Dingen der Starts und Landungen. Und dieses Flugzeug hat irgendwie 5000, 6000 Flugstunden. Das macht also ein normaler Ferienflieger in zwei Jahren. Und die Anzahl der Parabeln liegt bei über 10.000, was dann etwa, wird so gerechnet, eine Parabel wie einmal Start und einmal Landung von der Belastung her. Aber jedenfalls ist das sicherlich eins der am besten gewartetsten und fittesten Flugzeuge der Welt. Da muss man sich keine Sorgen machen. Und die Veränderungen halten sich sehr in Grenzen. Natürlich sind im mittleren Bereich dieses Flugzeugs alle Sitze rausgenommen. Nur noch vorne und hinten gibt es Sitze für Start und Landung für die Mitflieger. Man hat alles ausgepolstert mit Matratzen, damit sich keiner verletzt in der Schwerelosigkeit. Und dann gibt es eine etwas kräftigere Energieversorgung, weil man muss ja auch die Experimente, die da drin immer fliegen, mit Elektrizität versorgen. Es gibt eine technische Konsole, wo online diverse Verhaltensparameter des Airbus aufgezeichnet werden. Was Hydraulik angeht, Kraftstoffversorgung, natürlich die jeweiligen Beschleunigungen werden aufgezeichnet in die drei Raumrichtungen. Und an der Hydraulik wurden auch gewisse Veränderungen vorgenommen.
Warum wird das aufgezeichnet? Ist das jetzt für die Experimente relevant? Als Vergleichsdaten?
Sowohl als auch. Also einmal die Experimente brauchen zum Beispiel die Beschleunigungsdaten sehr genau, sekundengenau. Das wird dann den Wissenschaftlern hinterher zur Verfügung gestellt. Aber man muss natürlich schon ein Flugzeug sehr genau beobachten, wie es sich verhält in solchen außergewöhnlichen Manövern, um eben da auch auf der sicheren Seite zu sein. Deswegen werden bestimmte Parameter da aufgezeichnet, sodass man die dann immer hinterher zur Hand hat. Aber auch währenddessen, sodass da sitzen also Flugtestingenieure, die beobachten ständig gewisse Parameter. Und die könnten dann warnen und sofort sagen, hier ist also irgendwo was nicht in Ordnung.
Also wo normalerweise eigentlich nur das Pilotenteam vorne im Cockpit sich um den Zustand der Maschine und des Fluges Sorgen machen muss, ist es hier eben zusätzlich zu den Piloten auch noch ein Team von, wie viele Leute sind das?
Also das ist an dieser Konsole sitzen ein bis zwei Testflugingenieure. Und es gibt dann aber noch andere, die für die allgemeine Sicherheit an Bord zuständig sind.
Okay, aber die beobachten sozusagen die ganze Zeit den Zustand des Flugzeuges.
Ja, genau.
Man muss noch sagen, das Flugzeug gehört jetzt nicht dem DLR, sondern wird von einer französischen Firma betrieben, Novels Bas.
Ja.
Das war auch schon immer so.
Das war immer so. Das ist eine Ausgründung aus der französischen Raumfahrtorganisation CNES. Diese kleine Firma ist eben fast ausschließlich für die Durchführung dieser Parabelflüge zuständig. Denn neben Deutschland, neben dem DLR, veranstaltet auch die französische Raumfahrtorganisation CNES und die europäische Raumfahrtorganisation ESA solche Parabelflüge. Und zwar in der Regel jeweils zwei pro Jahr, wie wir das auch machen, sodass also sechsmal pro Jahr das Flugzeug für solche Parabelflug, wir nennen das Kampagnen, also Wissenschaftskampagnen, eingesetzt wird. Und der Heimatflughafen ist Bordeaux-Merignac. Und da sind dann auch Gebäude, wo die Wissenschaftler ihre Experimente dann letztendlich vor dem Flug noch flugfertig machen. Kleine Labors, wo die Mediziner, aber auch die Physiker und die Biologen ihre Proben vorbereiten oder hinterher analysieren können. Und da steht dann auch das Flugzeug sozusagen direkt vor der Tür, sodass man da auch immer raus und rein kann, um das alles vorzubereiten.
Und die Kampagne wird jetzt auch in mehreren Orten dann immer durchgeführt, unter anderem auch in Bordeaux.
Also normalerweise ist standardmäßig eine solche Kampagne in Bordeaux, weil eben das Flugzeug da steht, weil auch direkt daneben gewartet wird, das Flugzeug gewartet wird. Und weil die Räumlichkeiten der Firma da optimal für uns zur Verfügung stehen. In Ausnahmefällen, auf besonderen Wunsch einer der Agentur, wenn sie das möchte, kann eine solche Kampagne auch woanders stattfinden. Das macht man zum Beispiel aus Gründen der Öffentlichkeitswirksamkeit, sodass wir seit 2004 zum fünften Mal hier am Flughafen Köln-Bonn mit einer solchen Kampagne waren. In den vergangenen Jahren haben wir dann die gesamte 14-tägige Kampagne hier durchgeführt. Das ist aber ein riesiger logistischer Aufwand, sodass wir bei dem Flug, wo sie auch dabei waren, es dabei belassen haben, nur für einige zusätzliche Flüge hier nach Köln zu kommen. Im Prinzip kann man das natürlich an jedem Flughafen machen, der eine gewisse Infrastruktur eben für die Vorbereitung von solchen Experimenten auch bieten kann. Und die französische Firma Novice Bus, die das eben in Europa anbietet, diese Flüge, die verpflichtet dann französische Testpiloten, weil die Oberaufsicht auf diese Experimentalflüge hat das französische Testflugzentrum des Verteidigungsministeriums, denn da gibt es eben auch wirklich viele Dinge zu prüfen, dass das auch alles sicher ist. Ich meine, normalerweise auf einem normalen Ferienflug hat man ja nicht gerade metallische Schmelzen und schmilzt die auf 2500 Grad heiß.
Nur eine Ausnahme für Inder.
Genau, oder zapft den Mitfliegern Blut ab. Also da müssen schon ganz erhebliche Menge an Regularien eingehalten werden und das beaufsichtigt eben das französische Verteidigungsministerium. Aber diese Piloten, das sind natürlich absolut Spitzenkönner ihres Fachs. Sogenannte experimentelle Testpiloten, die also noch mehrere Zusatzausbildungen haben. Und die werden auch regelmäßig vor jeder Kampagne nochmal machen die Trainingsflüge mit diesem Airbus und probieren also nichts anderes aus, als gute Parabeln zu fliegen. Das ist immer dasselbe Team an Piloten, natürlich mit Backups. Also da stehen irgendwie fünf, sechs zur Verfügung. Und die fliegen also diese sechs Kampagnen pro Jahr.
So ein bisschen auch wie die Besatzungen der ISS, die auch so als Teams ausgebildet werden, Backups haben und auch hohe Verlässlichkeit haben.
Hier kommt ja noch dazu, dass nicht ein Pilot alleine so eine Parabel fliegen könnte, sondern die drei Raumrichtungen, in der sich ein Flugzeug bewegen kann, die werden aufgeteilt auf drei Personen. Der eine Pilot ist nur für sogenannte Pitch-Achse des Flugzeugs zuständig, also ob die Nase rauf oder runter geht. Und der andere Pilot ist für die Roll-Achse des Flugzeugs zuständig, also um die Lenksachse sich bewegen. Und ein Flugingenieur bedient die Triebwerke, also die dritte Raumrichtung. Und das heißt, ich habe die drei Raumrichtungen, in der sich das Flugzeug bewegen kann, auf drei Personen aufgeteilt. Weil die Bedienung für jede einzelne Raumrichtung ist dermaßen schwierig in einer solchen Parabel, dass das immer nur jeweils ein Mensch machen kann. Und natürlich, da ja jetzt das Flugzeug sich immer gleichzeitig in drei Raumrichtungen bewegt, müssen diese drei Personen maximal optimal aufeinander eintrainiert sein, dass da jeder in jedem Augenblick die richtige Lenkung vornimmt.
Aber an meinem Heimcomputer habe ich gelernt, dass ich Raumschiffe auch mit einem einzigen Joystick steuern kann. Was macht das jetzt so schwierig, dass man das auf drei Rollen verteilt?
Ja, das ist diese Kurve zu fliegen, diese parabelförmige Kurve des Flugzeugs. Da sind viele Aspekte zu berücksichtigen. Jedes Flugzeug hat natürlich auch bestimmtes Flugverhalten. Und z.B. in dieser Parabel, wenn das Flugzeug schwerelos ist, fliegt es nicht mehr nach aerodynamischen Gesichtspunkten, sondern es fällt wie ein Stein. Damit es das machen kann, muss der Anstellwinkel des Flugzeugs in Richtung seiner Bewegung negativ sein. Also ein normales Flugzeug, das kann man ja bei jedem Flug feststellen, steht ja immer ein bisschen mit der Nase nach oben, wenn es so fliegt. Ich weiß nicht, 4-5 Grad nach oben von der Horizontalen fliegt es, wenn es seine normale Reiseflughöhe erreicht hat.
Weil es ja eigentlich ein Luftschiff ist und durch die Luft durchflügt.
Ja, genau. Und die Flügel müssen eben in einem bestimmten Winkel stehen, damit sie da den optimalen Auftrieb bekommen. Und da aber, um Schwerelosigkeit zu erzeugen, genau dieser Auftrieb, ja entgegen dem Gewicht, das ausbalanciert, also null die Kräfte sein sollen, darf es eben keinen Auftrieb haben. Und deswegen muss es nicht nur exakt horizontal oder parallel zur Bewegungsrichtung fliegen, sondern sogar mit einem negativen Anstellwinkel von 4-5 Grad. Und alleine das eben immer hinzukriegen, ist schon eine Anforderung. Vor allen Dingen aber deswegen, wir müssen uns die Luft, den Himmel ja nicht vorstellen als eine absolut ruhige Umgebung, sondern es gibt immer Turbulenzen, die Luft ist immer in Bewegung. Und sie arbeitet natürlich an dem Flugzeug. Und gerade wenn sich das Flugzeug in einer solchen Bahn befindet, wirken diese Turbulenzen in besonderem Maße.
Weil das Flugzeug keine eigene Stabilisierung mit sich bringt.
Und gegen diese Turbulenzen muss dauernd angelängt werden. Und das müssen die ausgleichen. Das können die Piloten auch nur in einem bestimmten Maß. Wenn wir also sehr schlechtes Wetter für diesen Flug haben, dann können sie das auch nicht mehr ausgleichen. Und dann werden die Parabeln schlecht. Und dann können die Wissenschaftler sie nicht mehr gut gebrauchen. Das heißt, die Aufgabe des Piloten vorher ist immer, möglichst aus dem meteorologischen Daten ein gutes, ruhiges Fluggebiet zu suchen. Aber es kann schon mal sein, aus den meteorologischen Daten kann man nicht alles erkennen.
Aber wenn jetzt die Anforderung an die Steuerung so komplex ist, warum nimmt man da nicht einen Autopiloten?
Das hat man also mal versucht in Ansätzen. Das war nicht erfolgreich. Und es muss wohl auch so sein, für dieses Manöver ein Autopilotenprogramm zu schreiben, zu machen, muss immens Geld kosten. Und man hat wohl festgestellt, also letztendlich wird das nicht erfolgreich sein, sondern da ist tatsächlich die Arbeit der Piloten, der Menschen immer noch das bessere. Und es ist so, dass bei einem solchen Parabelflug natürlich auch nicht absolute Schwerelosigkeit herrscht. Die herrscht aber auf keinem. Auch nicht auf einer Rakete und auch nicht im Fallturm.
Auch nicht auf der ISS?
Auch nicht auf der ISS. Da sind immer noch Störungen in verschiedenen Bereichen. Also einer der besten ist immer noch der Fallturm, wo dann die Störungen nur im Bereich von 10 noch minus 6 g sind. Auf dem Parabelflug sind die Störungen der Schwerelosigkeit im Bereich von einigen 100 g. Also das muss man wissen, wenn man da experimentiert.
100 zell g.
Also einige hundertstel g.
Von 100 g hab ich nichts gebernt.
Einige hundertstel g.
Deswegen spricht man auch von Mikro-Gravitation.
Ja, von Mikro im Sinne von klein. Nicht exakt Mikro im Bereich von tausendstel. Ja. Also bisher fliegt man das eben weltweit mit Piloten. Diese Manöver. Und besser als mit diesen hundertstel g-Störungen kann man das mit dem Flugzeug sowieso nicht hinkriegen.
Bevor wir nochmal auf die Details des Flugs hinkommen, jetzt frage ich mich gerade, wie war denn das eigentlich bevor dieser super stabile und super performante A300 am Start war? Also sind da die Parabelflüge mit erfunden worden?
Also sicherlich haben die ersten Pioniere in den fliegenden Kisten, wenn die so verrückte Manöver geflogen sind, so in den 20er, 30er, da haben die sicher auch mal eine Parabel geflogen. Das können auch Segelflugzeuge oder kleine Sportflugzeuge ganz kurzzeitig. Das sollte man nur nicht öfters machen, weil das dem Flugzeug eben nicht gut tut.
Oder dem Körper.
Ja, ja, auch das. Die richtig mit Parabelflügen begonnen hat man so in den 50er Jahren des letzten Jahrhunderts. Und zwar waren die beiden deutschen Physiker Fritz und Heinz Haber mit, kann man sagen, Begründer der wissenschaftlichen Parabelflüge, weil sie eine Veröffentlichung geschrieben haben, wie kann man Schwerelosigkeit mit so einem Flugzeug herstellen und welche Forschung könnte man da machen, insbesondere auch Richtung Raumfahrtmedizin. Und dann hat man sowohl in Frankreich als auch in USA bald mit solchen Flügen, vom militärischen Seite natürlich, mit Militärflugzeugen begonnen und hat einmal sie genutzt, um die Wirkung von kurzzeitiger Schwerelosigkeit auf den menschlichen Körper zu untersuchen. Und das natürlich auch ganz besonders in Vorbereitung für die damals anlaufenden Mondflüge der Amerikaner. Apollo-Programm, erst aber Mercury-Programm, sodass eben alle Astronauten, die damals im Training waren, dann auch solche Parabelflüge gemacht haben. Und die Franzosen, die Russen haben das dann auch gemacht. Und erst so seit den Mitte der 80er-Jahre hat man neben diesen mehr Trainingsaspekten oder auch Raumfahrtmedizinischen Aspekten hat man dann entdeckt, okay, Parabelflüge ist Schwerelosigkeit in kurzen Zeiten, kann man aber in vielen Wissenschaftsbereichen was Sinnvolles mitmachen. Und dann hat man in den USA und in Europa eben mit diesen regelmäßigen Parabelflügen zu wissenschaftlichen Zwecken begonnen.
Wir reden von dem Heinz Haber, der dann auch später im Fernsehen sehr bekannt geworden ist mit seinen Sendungen über den Weltraum.
Ganz genau. Er und sein Bruder, die haben eben am Anfang zeitweise in den USA gelebt, auch zu Zeiten, wo Werner von Braun in den USA war. Und haben da an amerikanischen Instituten, am amerikanischen flugmedizinischen Institut gearbeitet. Und in dem Zusammenhang kamen dann eben auch diese Parabelflüge auf.
Ja, kommen wir wieder zurück zu dem aktuellen Parabelflügen im A300. Das haben wir jetzt gelernt. Das ist also ein speziell umgebautes Teil von den Piloten. Dahinter diese spezielle Technikkonsole. Dann gibt es so einen kleinen Sitzbereich. Dann in der Mitte diese große Spielwiese, wo man erstens schön herumfliegen kann mit so aufgespannten Fangnetzen und Spanngurten, damit man sich dann auch im richtigen Moment nochmal festhalten kann. Sehr sinnvolle Einrichtung, wie ich feststellen durfte.
Wenn ich da einhaken darf, die ist aber nur bei solchen Spezialflügen, wie wir da an dem Wochenende gemacht haben. Normalerweise ist das gesamte Flugzeug außerhalb der Sitze gefüllt mit Wissenschaft, von vorne bis hinten. Es gibt also nur so einen winzigen Käfig, wo man mal einen Putzelbaum schlagen kann. Denn der andere Platz wird wirklich gebraucht. Wir haben da normalerweise 12, 13, 14 Experimentanlagen an Bord.
Genau, und das sind dann einfach größere Geräte. Manche sind auch ein bisschen kleiner, teilweise auch ziemliche Boliden, die dann auf den Boden festgeschraubt werden. Drumherum gibt es auch viele Spanngurte, um dann auch die Menschen, damit sie sich vor allem vor diesem Gerät festschnallen können, um nicht wegzufliegen in dem Moment, wo es dann interessant wird. Hinten gibt es dann noch mal einen Sitzbereich, weil bei Start und Landung muss man ja ganz normal, wie man das eben auch kennt, auch sitzen. Diese spezielle Stromversorgung, die Sie angesprochen hatten, also ich kann mir vorstellen, wenn da jetzt 13, 14 Experimente sind, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele davon üblicherweise viel Strom brauchen, aber kann ja schon sein, dass es mal ein paar mehr sind, wodurch wird die bereitgestellt? Also fällt das einfach aus den normalen Triebwerken ab oder gibt es noch mal einen separaten?
Also das fällt dann aus den Triebwerken ab. Da gibt es dann im Cargo-Bereich, also im Bauch des Flugzeugs, gibt es dann noch mal bestimmte Geräte, die die Energieversorgung in einer ordentlichen Art und Weise gleichmäßig für die Experimente zur Verfügung stellen. Aber sie ist natürlich in so einem Flugzeug in der Tat begrenzt. Und deswegen müssen wir auch immer schauen, dass aus der Gruppe an Experimenten, die auf einem solchen Parabelflug stattfinden sollen, dass wir da eine gute Zusammensetzung auswählen von Geräten, die viel Energie brauchen, wie zum Beispiel eben für die Materialforschung, so Öfen, die da heizen und so weiter. Und Experimenten, die wenig Energie brauchen. Das ist meistens in der Medizin. Die haben da kleine Gerätchen, die haben drei Batterien und gut ist. Die brauchen dann da nicht viel Flugzeugenergie zu ziehen. Also das muss austariert sein. Dann müssen wir austarieren, wie viel Quadratmeter pro Experiment verwendet werden an Bord. Weil wir haben einen sehr großen Bereich. Das sind 100 Quadratmeter. Also 25 mal 4 Meter so ungefähr ist die Fläche. Das ist wirklich viel. Aber aufgeteilt auf 12, 13 Experimente, da muss man schon schieben und arrangieren, dass jedes Experiment genügend Platz hat mit seinen Bedienern. Denn das ist ja nun mal das große Plus der Parabelflüge gegenüber anderen Fluggelegenheiten, dass die Menschen mit an Bord können und ihr Experiment selber durchführen. Sie können also beobachten, sie können eingreifen in ihr Experiment, sie können Parameter verändern. Das ist sozusagen wie Forschung normal, wie Forschung am Boden auch.
Und man hat deutlich mehr Platz, man kann deutlich mehr Gewicht mitbringen, viel größere Maschinen zum Einsatz bringen. Dann eben die Stromzufuhr hatten wir ja schon.
Ja, also wir haben durchaus Geräte, wo das einzelne Gerät 1,5 Tonnen wiegt. Das bekäme man natürlich nicht gerade so auf die Raumstation. Das ist der Vorteil, dass beim Parabelflug nimmt man wirklich die Geräte, die die Wissenschaftler in Labor zu Hause stehen haben. Die werden dann in bestimmte Halterungen, in kräftige Racks eingebaut. Und da müssen auch Berechnungen gemacht werden, Schwerpunkt und Lasten und so weiter. Denn das muss alles so ausgerichtet sein, wird ja befestigt am Flugzeugboden, dort wo sonst die Sitze befestigt sind. Aber das Flugzeug könnte ja sein, dass es eine Notlandung machen muss. Und wenn das ein bisschen zu fest aufsetzt, dann können also Kräfte maximal bis 9G auftreten. Und jedes Gerät muss jetzt so gebaut sein, dass es eine solche Notlandung aushalten würde. Und eben nicht wie bei Notbremsung beim Auto, dass dann von hinten sämtliche Kisten nach vorne fliegen und den Leuten ins Genick. Also gewisse Sicherheitsregularien müssen da eingehalten werden.
Jetzt wird langsam auch klar, warum man überhaupt so viel Vorlauf braucht. Also all diese Bestückungen, Anordnungen, etc. müssen aufeinander abgestimmt werden. Energiebedarf muss abgestimmt werden. Wenn das dann... Vielleicht springen wir noch mal ein bisschen zurück in diesen organisatorischen Vorbereitungsphasen. Also abgesehen jetzt von den wissenschaftlichen Experimenten. Die Piloten, die bereiten sich eigenständig vor. Was fällt noch an?
Also die Vorbereitung läuft konkret sieben Monate lang. Wir haben dann diese Experimente ausgewählt. Und die Wissenschaftler bereiten dann die Experimente zu Hause bei sich vor. Die bekommen Besuch von einem Ingenieur von NoviceBus, der sich dann vor Ort alles genau anguckt und sie auch berät, die Wissenschaftler, ob sie dies oder jenes vielleicht so und so machen sollten, damit das Gerät den Bestimmungen entspricht. Und dann müssen alle medizinischen Experimente sich einer ethischen Kommission dem Votum vorstellen, ob sie ethischen Prinzipien entsprechen, ob also das, was da gemacht werden soll, mit oder an den Menschen ethisch zulässig ist.
Also wird das sein Überprüf, dass da keiner gefoltert wird in der Schwierigkeit?
Richtig, genau. Und ob das, ob man, ob alles zumutbar ist und ob die wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis, die man rauszieht, in einem akzeptablen Verhältnis steht zu dem in Anführungsstrichen Gefahr, die sich der Proband unterzieht. Also jeder, der zum Beispiel Blut abgenommen kriegt, könnte ja eine Infektion an dieser Entnahmestelle bekommen. Oder jemand, der Parabelfliegt, kriegt eine Panikattacke und seitdem möchte er nicht mehr in ein Flugzeug gehen und so weiter. Also das muss natürlich geprüft werden. Das wird schon in Deutschland von den zuständigen lokalen Ethikkommissionen überprüft. Aber in Frankreich gibt es dann nochmal für den gesamten Parabelflug eine solche Ethikkommission und das wird geprüft für alle medizinischen Experimente. Dann was giftige Chemikalien zum Beispiel angeht oder sonstige gefährliche, potenziell gefährliche Einrichtungen wie Flaschen, die unter Druck stehen oder Laser. Das alles muss genau überprüft werden. Da gibt es also insgesamt in diesen sieben Monaten Vorbereitungszeit fünf oder sechs sogenannte Reviews, wo dann jedes Experiment geprüft wird von Fachleuten in Frankreich, ob auch alles so zulässig ist und gut gemacht wird. Es wird Ratschläge gegeben, wie man das alles sicher verpacken kann.
In Ausgabe Nummer 14 von Raumzeit war ich beim DLR in Oberpaffenhofen. Da ging es um Robotik in der Raumfahrt. Da kam auch schon sehr stark zur Sprache, wie groß doch die Anforderungen sind für Wissenschaftler, ihr Gerät auf einer Mission mitzunehmen. In dem Fall ging es um die Space Lab Mission. Wie viel sichergestellt werden muss, was die Geräte alles durchmachen müssen. Auch der Start, auch hier die besondere Belastung. Im Prinzip ist ja auch an der Stelle so ein Parabelflug für die Wissenschaftler auch schon mal so ein Testfeld, was organisatorisch alles zu leisten ist, um einfach mitfliegen zu dürfen.
Das ist völlig richtig und das sagen auch Gruppen, die sowohl bei einem Parabelflug als auch bei einer sogenannten großen Mission, also meinetwegen Space Lab Mission dabei waren oder jetzt auf der ISS mitfliegen wollen, dass Parabelflug und die gesamten Vorbereitungen ein Testbett sind. Weil der Termin steht fest, wann der Parabelflug sein wird und das Experiment muss exakt einen Tag vorher fertig sein. Es muss funktionieren, es muss so sein, dass die Wissenschaft, die gewünscht wird, damit auch rauskommt. Und es muss alles fix und fertig sein und natürlich eben die Sicherheitsanforderungen erfüllen. Und natürlich arbeiten Wissenschaftler in ihrem Labor auch mit einem gewissen Zeitplan. Aber gut, wenn es dann einen Tag später oder wenn irgendein Teil, was man bestellt hat, später kommt, naja gut, dann wird es eben leider ein bisschen später. Macht nichts. Das geht hier nicht. Sondern man muss sich wirklich einen sehr guten Terminplan machen, um rückwärts zu rechnen, wann muss was erfolgt sein. Und man sollte auch ein Team bilden für jedes Experiment, wo die Verantwortlichkeiten gut verteilt sind, dass jeder weiß, ich bin für das und das verantwortlich und der andere für etwas anderes. Und dass auch jeder wirklich sein Gebiet vollverantwortlich überblickt und nicht denkt, naja, das wird der andere dann schon machen und nachher stellt sich raus, hat keiner gemacht. Es müssen auch Vertretungsregelungen, wenn einer in Urlaub ist, mal krank wird, ein Kind kriegt und so weiter, das muss auch alles gemacht werden. Das heißt, diese Projekte, wie auch das gesamte Parabelflugprojekt für sich, sind eben gute Übungsfelder für Organisieren, für Teambildung, auch für Zusammenarbeit. In den meisten Wissenschaftlerteams sind auch Jungforscher aus anderen Ländern mit dabei. Das ist also so ein normaler Parabelflug. Wenn ich da so in die Listen gucke, dann sehe ich meistens durchschnittlich Menschen aus etwa zehn verschiedenen Ländern, dass die dabei sind. Man muss auch so ein bisschen interkulturell gucken, dass sich die Leute im Team integrieren. Also es sind wirklich viele Aspekte, die rein von der Organisation in jedem Experimentprojekt da zu beachten sind. Und was so das gesamte Parabelflugprojekt angeht, das ist ja auch so das Interessante, dass eben Teilnehmer der verschiedensten Berufe hier zusammenarbeiten müssen. Also wir müssen Verträge machen, da gucken die Juristen mit rein. Das Ganze muss finanziell ordentlich kalkuliert sein, da gucken die Betriebswirte mit rein. Dann haben wir natürlich die Piloten. Dann ganz wichtig das Wartungspersonal, was jeden Morgen um 6 Uhr den Airbus fertig macht, damit wir um 9.30 Uhr endlich losfliegen können. Dann haben wir diese ganzen Ingenieure, Mechaniker, Sicherheitsingenieure, die sich um die Technik kümmern. Bei den Wissenschaftlern, technische Assistenten, die Werkstätten in den Universitäten. Natürlich die verschiedenen Wissenschaftler aus den vielen verschiedenen Bereichen. Und dann eben die sogenannten Manager, so wie ich selber eine bin, die eben so alles überblicken müssen und für alles zuständig und verantwortlich sind. Dann noch Leute, die sich um die Presse- und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit kümmern, Kollegen von mir. Und dann haben wir auch immer wieder Schulprojekte für Schüler, 18-jährige Schüler mit dabei. Da ist dann unser School Lab aus dem DLR mit integriert. Also es sind sehr viele verschiedene Aspekte, die da so reinreichen. Und das macht es auch sehr vielseitig und interessant.
Neben der Gerätesicherheit und der organisatorischen Vorbereitung müssen ja auch die Menschen selber flugtauglich sein. Dazu ist ja auch eine gewisse medizinische Grundvoraussetzung zu erfüllen. Also man muss fit sein. Also man darf zumindest jetzt keine offensichtlichen Gebrechlichkeiten vor sich her tragen. Man muss ja da auch durch einen entsprechenden medizinischen Check durchgehen. Der muss dann auch immer wieder von allen durchgeführt werden.
Das ist richtig, genau. Also man muss eine Fliegertauglichkeitsuntersuchung machen. Die hat so das Anforderungsniveau, als wolle man Privatpilot werden. Also man darf keine schweren Krankheiten haben, durchschnittlich gesund. Da ist jetzt nicht eine besondere Fitness gefordert. Aber eben durchschnittlich gesund. Denn so ein normaler Parabelflugtag hat ja 30 Parabeln, 31 Parabeln, um genau zu sein. Und diese ständigen Wechsel an Beschleunigungen, normale Schwerkraft, diese Doppelschwerkraft, die zieht einen schon kräftig nach unten, drückt auf den Körper. Die Schwerelosigkeit ist eher vergnüglich. Dann wieder Doppelschwerkraft. Dann wieder normale Schwerkraft. Also diese ständigen Wechsel, die sind ganz schön anstrengend, auch für das Herz-Kreislauf-System. Und selbst wenn man das stehend durchmacht, weil man muss vielleicht, entsprechend der Aufgabe, dann kriegt man zum Beispiel Muskelkater oder kann kriegen Muskelkater in den Oberschenkeln, weil man gegen diese Doppel-G-Phase so ankämpfen muss. Also das ist schon eine ganz schöne Belastung. Und selbst junge Mitflieger sagen, nach so einem Tag bin ich müde. Und nach drei Flugtagen, die wir ja normalerweise anbieten in dieser Kampagne, da haben die meisten Leute wirklich genug.
Schnauze voll, genug Parabeln geflogen. Können wir noch vielleicht mal auf den konkreten Flugtag zu sprechen? Alle müssen pünktlich sein, ganz klar. Es ist alles auch wirklich auf die Minute hin getimt. Man kriegt ja vorher schon relativ ausführlichen Zeitplan und es wird auch keine Gelegenheit ausgelassen, um klarzumachen, dass der auch genauso zu erfolgen habe. Letztlich hängt man natürlich dann doch auch vom Wetter ab. Ich weiß nicht, kam das schon mal vor, dass das Wetter einem jetzt komplett einen Strich durch die Rechnung gemacht hat? Oder heißt das nur, dass man dann woanders hinfliegt?
Ja, genau, also komplett durch den Strich durch die Rechnung macht das nicht. Weil der Pilot hat, der sieht ja, wo ist welches Wetter. Und er hat mehrere Fluggebiete, wo er grundsätzlich hinfliegen kann. Und er versucht durch die Auswahl natürlich schon, jegliches Wetterrisiko zu minimieren. Und in der Regel funktioniert das auch. Es kommt ganz, ganz selten nur vor, dass man dann während des Fluges feststellt, also die Kleinturpolenzen, die sind doch so stark, dass wir hier einfach keine ordentlichen Parabeln fliegen. Dann machen sie Suchflüge. Dann fliegen sie also erstmal ein Viertelstunde in eine bestimmte Richtung, probieren da wieder eine Parabel, hoffen, dass es besser geht. Und in der Regel, also irgendwie finden sie es dann schon.
Wo fliegt man denn eigentlich?
Also wenn wir von Bordeaux aus fliegen, was ja der Heimatflughafen ist, dann gibt es einmal große militärische Flug-Testgebiete, Test Areas, wo die französische Luftwaffe ihre Übungsflüge macht über dem Golf von Biscaya, also zwischen Bordeaux und der Britannie, auf dem Atlantik riesengroßes Gebiet. Da fliegen wir meistens hin, weil das auch der kürzeste Anflug von Bordeaux aus ist. Wenn da das Wetter großflächig schlecht ist, dann fliegen wir aufs Mittelmeer raus, Richtung Corsica und Sardinien. Da sind es auch große Gebiete, die da zur Verfügung stehen. Und wenn aus irgendwelchen Gründen das aber auch nicht geht, dann kann man auch Richtung Paris über Land fliegen.
Also man muss jetzt nicht über dem Meer sein, das ist nicht die Voraussetzung?
Es ist nicht die Voraussetzung, schon gar nicht jetzt aus Sicherheitsgründen, dass man sagt, wenn er abstürzt, dann ins Meer. Das ist nicht der Punkt, sondern in der Regel sind über dem Meer die Luftturbulenzen geringer als über Land. Allein durch die Topographie. Und das ist der Grund, warum man übers Meer fliegt. Und weil dort eben zumindest von französischer Seite aus die großen Fluggebiete, die für anderen Flugverkehr gesperrt sind, liegen. Sodass man dann auch nicht so viel Interferenz hat mit anderen Flugzeugen. Denn natürlich das Gebiet konkret, wo der Airbus dann seine Parabeln fliegt, da darf jetzt kein anderes Flugzeug sein. Denn wenn der Airbus, wenn die Piloten eine Parabel begonnen haben, dann muss die durchgeflogen werden. Er kann die nicht abbrechen. Das geht einfach nicht. Und insofern muss eben ein gewisses Gebiet auf jeden Fall von anderen Verkehr frei sein.
Das ist ja vor allem deshalb schwierig, weil man ja die Höhe wechselt. Normalerweise basiert ja auch die Flugsicherheit darauf, dass man sagt, der ist auf der Höhe, der ist auf der Höhe. Aber welcher Höhenunterschied wird in dieser Parabel überhaupt bewältigt?
Das sind zweieinhalb Kilometer. Also wir fliegen zwischen 6.500 oder 6.100 Kilometer und 8.500 bis 8.700 Metern. Also die Piloten würden das jetzt in Fuß sagen, aber wir sind ja normale.
Okay, also schon unter der üblichen Reiseflughöhe eigentlich. Aber schon sozusagen genau in diesem kritischen Bereich des Hoch- und Runters, wo man überhaupt noch ausweichen könnte. Und deswegen muss einfach der Bereich frei sein.
Ja, vorbei dieser Bereich, in dem die Parabeln durchgeführt werden, der ist nicht gewählt, weil darüber die Fernflüge stattfinden, sondern weil in diesem Bereich die Performance, also die Leistung der Turbinen in Relation zum Luftwiderstand usw. am besten ist. Also das gesamte Verhalten des Flugzeugs mit seinen Turbinen ist in diesem Bereich für die Parabeln am besten.
Verstehe. Als wir in Köln losgeflogen sind, wohin ging es da?
Über die Nordsee. Da gibt es nämlich von deutscher Seite aus ein solches Trainingsgebiet für das Militär. Und dieses buchen wir dann über die deutsche Flugsicherung und können dann die Parabeln dort fliegen. Und wenn da das Wetter zu schlecht gewesen wäre, ganz toll war es diesmal auch nicht, aber wenn es noch schlechter gewesen wäre, dann hätten wir noch nach Ostdeutschland ausweichen können. Wenn das auch schlecht gewesen wäre, dann hätten wir nach Frankreich fliegen müssen. Aber das heißt natürlich längere Anflug und damit längere Dauer überhaupt von dem Flug.
Ja, insofern hat es geklappt. Wir waren dann über die Nordsee. Ich weiß nicht, haben wir jetzt von diesem Vorbereitungsteil noch irgendwas Entscheidendes ausgelassen? Ja, nicht. Vielleicht gehen wir mal so kurz in diesen Flug rein, dass man sich klarmachen kann, wie das eigentlich abläuft.
Also kurz vor dem Flug gibt es ja noch die Safety-Briefing. Wenn Sie sich erinnern, entweder am Abend vorher oder gegebenenfalls auch an dem Tag direkt, wo der Parabelflug ist, muss man ja noch intensiv auf diesen Flug vorbereitet werden. Da gibt es viele Informationen. Wie läuft das denn alles ab? Wie fliegt man überhaupt diese Manöver? Wie fliegt man die Maschine, dass wir Schwerelosigkeit kriegen? Welche Wissenschaft ist drauf? Und die üblichen Sicherheitshinweise, die dann auch noch im Flugzeug gegeben werden. Aber eine Besonderheit ist vielleicht ganz nett. Vor allen Dingen ist das für alle was zum Lachen. Weil nämlich zusätzlich zu der Sauerstoffmaske, die ja üblicherweise beim Flugzeug aus der Decke fällt, wenn es einen Druckverlust gibt, und der Schwimmweste, die irgendwo unter dem Sitz angebracht ist, gibt es bei uns noch einen Helm, eine Kopfkappe, die man überziehen kann, sollte es zu Rauchentwicklung im Flugzeug kommen. Denn wir sind ja ein Experimentalflugzeug, haben zum Teil Feuer an Bord, Flammen oder entzündeten...
Plassenen, was da nicht alles ist.
Genau.
Kleine Sonnen, die gezündet werden.
Ja, da könnte ja auch mal Rauchentwicklung irgendwas schmoren oder so. Dann kann man diesen Helm überstülpen, der für 20 Minuten das Überleben eben auch mit frischem Sauerstoff garantiert.
Also ist es mehr so eine Supermarkttüte, die man so über den Kopf rüber zieht. Und dann kommt aber da Sauerstoff rein und man ist einfach komplett isoliert.
Richtig, genau. Das ist eine zusätzliche Absicherung zu diesem System aus dem Flugzeug. Genau, und dann, wenn man das alles weiß und verinnerlicht hat und auch weiß, wie man sich überhaupt verhalten soll, vor allen Dingen in dieser Doppel-G-Phase, wo unser Gleichgewichtssinn besonders irritabel ist, also besonders durch Bewegungen durcheinander gebracht werden könnte, da soll man sich also völlig still verhalten, den Kopf stillhalten, mit den Augen einen Punkt an der gegenüberliegenden Wand fixieren und sich nur ja nicht bewegen. Das hilft, dass man diese Flüge problemlos überstehen kann.
Ja, das Thema hatten wir auch schon angesprochen in Ausgabe 21, die schon besagte Sendung zu Raumfahrtmedizin. Der Trick ist einfach, dass der Körper ja verwirrt wird durch die unterschiedliche Wahrnehmung. Auf der einen Seite sieht man Bewegungen, auf der anderen Seite liegt der Gleichgewichtssinn einfach platt da, wird einfach niedergedrückt und denkt, da darf sich nichts bewegen. Und wenn diese doppelte, sich widersprechende Information beim Gehirn ankommt, kann es eben sein, dass das Hirn sagt, hier läuft alles drunter und drüber, du bist wahrscheinlich vergiftet, übergib dich mal ein bisschen.
Genau, völlig richtig. Das ist eben dieser intersensorische Konflikt, wie die Fachleute sagen.
Schönes Wort.
Der Konflikt zwischen zwei verschiedenen Sinnen, nämlich dem Sehsinn und dem Gleichgewichtssinn, der ja im Gehirn verschaltet und verrechnet wird. Und da sind verschiedene im Konflikt stehende Informationen. Und das kann eben zu dieser Übelkeit führen. Und dazu kommt noch diese Doppel-G-Phase, wo man also doppelt so schwer ist, wo dann die leichtesten Bewegungen des Kopfes ein stärkeres Signal, nämlich verdoppelt gegenüber der Erde, auch noch aufbringt. Und wenn das dann noch durch Kopfbewegungen oder Augenbewegungen dann auch noch durcheinander gebracht wird, also dann reicht es einfach manchen. Und das sollte man vermeiden. Diese Parabeln sind natürlich schon ein krasser Reiz. Und damit die Wissenschaftler, die ja auch 30 Parabeln überstehen müssen, damit sie trotzdem sicher und gut arbeiten können, denn die Wissenschaft steht im Vordergrund. Sie wollen was herausbekommen. Und sie haben sich monatelang darauf vorbereitet, das herauszubekommen. Deswegen gibt es eine Medikation vor dem Flug, die unser vegetatives Nervensystem etwas ruhig stellt, sodass also diese Empfindlichkeiten und damit auch diese Übelkeit in der Regel dann nicht mehr auftritt.
Da wird man gespritzt. Das ist die Prozedur, die man als letztes, halbe Stunde vorher war das glaube ich, über sich ergehen lassen, nicht muss, aber sollte. Da wird einem dann auch so ein bisschen schwammig, sage ich mal, es wird einem nicht übel, aber man wird so ein bisschen entspannt. Man hat den netten Nebeneffekt, dass man auch diese Anspannung ein bisschen los wird. Aber man kriegt ja einfach vorher auch so viel gesteckt, wie furchtbar schlecht einem werden könnte, dass man dann nur gar keinen Fehler machen soll. Das ist glaube ich für den Erstpfleger vollkommen normal, dass man dann aber auch wirklich ein bisschen aufgeregt ist und so an der Stelle ist die Medikation ganz hilfreich gewesen, weil man wird dann einfach so ein bisschen puffig und ein bisschen entspannter und denkt sich so, hm, ok, alles klar, ich mein, das Flugzeug wird schon nicht so schlimm werden. Ja, dann wird man angekarrt. Das ist nicht anders als beim normalen Flugzeug, steigt ein und macht sich erstmal ein bisschen vertraut. Die Geräte werden aber schon deutlich früher installiert.
Die Geräte sind in dieser normalen zweiwöchigen Kampagne werden die in der ersten Woche eingebaut. Und in der zweiten Woche gibt es die Flugtage. Und wenn dann diese zusätzlichen Flugtage sind, dann sind diese Geräte einfach an Bord. Genau, und die Wissenschaftler sind auch schon ein bisschen früher als die Gäste an Bord gekommen und haben dann so die allerletzten Einstellungen an ihren Geräten vorgenommen, sodass bis zum Start dann wirklich auch alles fix und fertig ist.
Bei unserem Flug gab es insofern vielleicht gar keine Besonderheit, aber es ist mir ja auch aufgefallen, dass vorher eben noch diese besagte Schulklasse, mit der die Kooperation lief, glaube ich auch vorher schon noch im Flugzeug war, bevor der zweite Teil der Besatzung nachgeliefert wurde. Was hat es denn mit dieser Zusammenarbeit da auf sich?
Ja, also mir ist es ein Anliegen und das ist auch ein Anliegen des DLR generell, dass man eben junge Menschen mit Hochtechnologie, mit Raumfahrt in diesem speziellen Fall, mit Schwerelosigkeitsforschung in Verbindung bringt, ihnen also zeigt, was gibt es da, was kann da gemacht werden. Und deswegen, so alle zwei Jahre, führe ich ein Projekt mit Schülern auf einem Parabelflug durch. Das heißt, zwei Schulen der Umgebung, Köln Bonner Raum, werden angesprochen, ob sie Lust haben, eben über ein paar Monate ein solches gemeinsames Projekt mit einem unserer School Labs hier in Köln durchzuführen. Wir bringen sie dann also in Kontakt mit einem Wissenschaftler, der ein Experiment an Bord hat und dessen Thematik sich ein sich eignet, dass man eben auch in der Schule begleitend da etwas machen kann. Und dann müssen diese Schulklassen oder Leistungskurse, also jedenfalls eine Gruppe von ungefähr 20 Schülerinnen und Schülern, die kommen dann ein paar Mal zu diesem School Lab hin, müssen auch Referate halten und werden dann in dieses Experiment eingeführt. Und pro Schule darf dann normalerweise ein Schüler mitfliegen und das Experiment an Bord dann auch selber zusammen mit dem Wissenschaftler durchführen. An diesem Wochenende, wo sie auch mitgeflogen sind, hatten wir das große Glück, dass noch zwei Plätze frei geworden waren, sodass also auch die Reservepersonen aus den beiden Schulen mitfliegen durften, was für die beiden jungen Leute natürlich sicherlich auch eine positive Überraschung war.
Ich habe zufällig den Moment der Verkündung mitbekommen, da haben sich zwei gefreut.
Da haben sich zwei sehr gefreut, denn die Backup-Person musste sich ja genauso vorbereiten, die musste medizinische Untersuchung gemacht haben, weil es hätte ja sein können, dass dem Hauptflieger kurz vorher, dass er sich ein Bein bricht oder eine kräftige Erkältung kriegt, also nicht hätte mitfliegen können. Und dann wäre normalerweise die Backup-Person eingetreten. Aber so konnten wir das machen. Und ich freue mich auch immer, wenn junge Leute, die sich auch besonders einsetzen in so einem Projekt, dann da auch das Erleben haben. Denn das ist ja nun doch ein sehr besonderes Erleben. Und das machen wir, wie gesagt, alle zwei Jahre, wenn der Parabelflug dann zumindest zum Teil hier in Deutschland stattfindet, weil logistisch die Schulklassen nach Bordeaux zu bekommen, das wäre doch etwas sehr schwierig. Haben wir in Einzelfällen auch schon gemacht, aber so lässt sich das hier dann besser organisieren.
Was war denn dann das Experiment, was dort begleitet wurde?
Da ging es um Wasserflöhe als Modellorganismus. Man will untersuchen, wie Wasserflöhe schwimmen, wenn der Parameter Schwerkraft wegfällt. Natürlich orientieren sie sich auf der Erde auch nach der Schwerkraft. Aber wie genau tun sie das eigentlich? Unbekannt. Ein Modellorganismus, den man in jedem Bach findet, lässt sich gut halten, kann man sogar in der Schule halten und kultivieren und damit Untersuchungen machen. Deswegen wählt man sowas aus. Ein zweiter Gedanke ist hier in der Raumfahrt, wird es in Zukunft neben diesen Aufenthalten auf der Raumstation auch Langzeitflüge geben, zum Beispiel Richtung Mars. Das wird noch einige zehn Jahre dauern. 2030, ich weiß es nicht, aber irgendwann wird es kommen. Das sind Flüge, wo die Astronauten dann durchaus zwei Jahre unterwegs sind. Da muss man natürlich auch ein bisschen an die Vielfalt der Verpflegung denken. Eine Idee könnte sein, dass man eben auch kleine Fische an Bord hat. Die brauchen wiederum Futter. Diese Bachflohkrepse könnten halt so ein Futter sein. Da müssen wir natürlich auch erst mal gucken, geht es denen überhaupt gut in Schwerelosigkeit? Das ist ein Seitenaspekt, den man auch untersuchen wird auf lange Sicht. Aber jetzt erst mal ging es wirklich um das Schwimmverhalten dieser Flohkrepse. Die sieht man gut und das ist etwas, was man sich auch in der Schule mal angucken kann. Insofern eignet sich dann so ein Experiment auch in der Kooperation mit Schulen. Man findet bei Schulen immer wieder äußerst engagierte Lehrer, die eben auch bereit sind, mit den Schülern zusammen in der Freizeit, weil das ist zusätzlich zum normalen Schulprogramm, an einem solchen Projekt teilzunehmen.
Sind das nicht Schulen, die jetzt eine spezielle wissenschaftliche Ausrichtung haben?
Nein, ganz normale Schulen der verschiedensten Ausrichtung werden da von uns angesprochen. Ein Teil von ihnen arbeitet schon sowieso mit einem solchen School Lab des DLR zusammen, wo Schulklassen dann über Tage zum Beispiel experimentieren können. Da ist ja hier eins im DLR in Köln. Der Leiter ist ein Biologe, das heißt, eine Verbindung zu biologischen Experimenten wird da natürlich auch besonders unterstützt. Er hat nämlich früher selber in seiner wissenschaftlichen Zeit auch Parabelflug-Experimente gemacht.
So, jetzt nähern wir uns dem Start. Los geht's. Erstmal ganz normaler Start. Da ist jetzt nichts anders. Und dann fliegt man eben in diesen besagten Sicherheitsbereich, in dem Fall halt die Nordsee. Ja, was man noch dazu sagen muss, es gibt halt permanente Kommunikation zwischen den Piloten, die die Durchsagen machen, zwischen den Piloten und allen, die sich da jetzt im Bauch des Wahls befinden, um einfach ganz klar zu kommunizieren, in welchem Zustand man sich jetzt gerade befindet, also wie nah ist jetzt sozusagen die nächste Parabel. Das heißt, wenn die richtige Flughöhe eingenommen wurde und es dann irgendwann losgehen kann, dann geht es halt auch los. Aber man kann ja nicht einfach anfangen, parabel zu fliegen, sondern man muss jedem die Gelegenheit geben, sich eben auf diesen Moment vorzubereiten, aus den zahlreichen bereits genannten Gründen, vor allem eben den medizinischen und um die richtige Position einnehmen zu können.
Genau, da kommen Durchsagen von den Piloten, die dann ja absehen können, okay, wir sind jetzt im richtigen Gebiet. Und man sagt, etwa zehn Minuten vorher, in zehn Minuten beginnt die erste Parabel. Denn viele Wissenschaftler müssen dann jetzt ihr Experiment in eine bestimmte Phase bringen, damit es dann in zehn Minuten auch dann echt bereit ist. Und dann kommen nochmal fünf Minuten und dann eine Minute vorher, 30 Sekunden, zehn, fünf, drei, zwei, eins, pull up. Das heißt, das ist das Kommando, das nun begonnen wird, das Flugzeug steil nach oben zu ziehen. Das dauert etwa 20 Sekunden lang. Und das Flugzeug weist nachher am Ende dieser Phase bis etwa 50 Grad mit der Nase nach oben. Das ist natürlich eine sehr ungewöhnliche Lage. Bei einem normalen Start eines Flugzeugs von der Rollbahn sind es bis zu 18 Grad, die so ein Flugzeug hochziehen kann. Aber hier beim Parabelflug eben bis zu 50 Grad.
Was ich erstaunlich fand in der Phase, ist, dass man das so gar nicht realisiert. Ich hab es zumindest so nicht gemerkt. Ich hab jetzt auch nicht aus dem Fenster geguckt.
Wenn man aus dem Fenster guckt, was auch ein sehr schönes Erlebnis ist, dann sieht man natürlich, dass die Relation des Flugzeugs zum Horizont eine sehr wilde ist, eine sehr ausgefallene. Nämlich ein Winkel von 50 Grad, das ist kolossal. Wenn man im Flugzeug selber drin ist, in dem Bereich, wo die Experimente sind, sind die Fenster, gibt es ja keine Fenster, alles ist mit diesen Matratzen ausgelegt. Und die Kraft, die auf uns wirkt durch diesen starken Aufwärtsbogen, ist ja eine Zentrifugalkraft, die senkrecht auf den Boden des Flugzeugs wirkt. Das heißt, wir meinen, da ist unten, naja, da ist ja normalerweise immer unten, ist also nichts Besonderes. Außer, dass wir jetzt doppelt so schwer sind, wie wir es normal sind.
Also nicht wirklich doppelt so schwer, ich glaube, es ist 1,5 bis 1,8.
Richtig, also in der bestimmten Phase 1,5 und dann aber 1,8-Fache der normalen Erdbeschleunigung wirkt auf uns. Und wenn man liegt, dann drückt einen kräftig auf den Boden, gut ist. Wenn man sitzt, merkt man schon kräftig. Ich weiß nicht, in welcher Lage haben Sie die Phase?
Ich habe meistens gestanden. Ich wollte das auch vollfühlen. Es war jetzt insofern, also man merkt es natürlich deutlich, also es drückt einen wirklich enorm nach unten. Mit den Beinen fand ich das jetzt gar nicht so problematisch, weil man ist es ja eigentlich gewohnt, wenn man sich abdrückt oder wogegen stemmt oder so. Also das ist jetzt kein wirklich ungewohntes Gefühl, nur dass es eben ohne eigene Aktivitäten auftrifft. Was ich am bemerkenswertesten fand in der Phase, ist, dass so das eigene Gehirn so auch ein bisschen in den Kopf hineingedrückt wird. Das war zumindest mein Empfinden in dem Moment. Ich weiß nicht, ob das allen so geht. Da hat man schon gemerkt, dass da so einiges auch in einem passiert.
Das ist sehr interessant. Diese Version habe ich noch nicht gehört. Das kommt dann erst meistens, wenn die Schwerelosigkeit beginnt. Aber die Erlebnisse, zwar passiert auf dem Körper bei allen Menschen das Gleiche, weil sie sind der gleichen Beschleunigung ausgesetzt. Aber wie man das wirklich persönlich erlebt, kann durchaus unterschiedlich sein. In dieser Phase wird ja auch geraten, dass man eine gewisse Pressatmung macht, also seinen Körper ein bisschen kräftig die Muskulatur anspannt. Denn gerade im Stehen wirkt ja nun der Gradient der Beschleunigung lang dem ganzen Körper. Also da noch das Blut dagegen ins Gehirn zu pumpen, ist natürlich doppelt so schwer, als wäre man normal auf der Erde. Das ist also auch kräftig eine Veränderung. Aber wie gesagt, wenn man gesund ist, wird man deswegen nicht ohnmächtig. Das schafft man dann.
Das war ganz gut zu bewältigen. Das hatte ich jetzt eigentlich keine Probleme.
Und damit man immer weiß, in welcher Phase sind wir jetzt, sagen die Piloten dann während dieser Aufwärtsphase den Grad, genau den Winkel an. Also 30 Grad, 40 Grad. Und dann kommt Injection. Injection heißt ein Schuss in die Schwerelosigkeit.
Man wird sozusagen in diese Parabel hinein indiziert.
Genau, genau.
Und dann gibt es nochmal so einen besonderen Moment. Also genau in diesem Injection-Moment, wenn auf einmal dieser Druck nachlässt, dann haben wir nochmal so eine halbe Sekunde, wird mir jetzt übel oder nicht, Moment.
Okay.
Also mir ging das auf jeden Fall so. Auf einmal ändert sich alles. Aber in dem Moment, wo man darüber nachdenkt, ist es dann eigentlich auch schon wieder vorbei. Und dann habe ich noch so den Eindruck gehabt, dass es so eine Sekunde dauert, bis sich das wirklich so voll entfaltet. Also die Parabel, die Null-G-Wirkung setzt nicht sofort ein, sondern es ist nochmal so ein sanfter Übergang.
Richtig, das sind also von dieser doppelten Beschleunigung oder 1,8G bis es wirklich Null-G wird, sind das nochmal zwei, drei Sekunden. Und da gibt es dann auch so erhebliche Fluktuationen allein durch die Flugtechnik. Da können auch mal sogenannte Negativ-G auftreten, also in die andere Richtung, als es vorher wirkte. Aber was passiert, ich meine, unsere Organe im Körper, die hängen ja normalerweise, werden eben gehalten durch Muskulatur und Gewebe. Und durch diese Schwankungen, die jetzt auftreten in der Beschleunigung, schwankt das natürlich. Das ist so dieser Effekt auch, wie wenn man mit einem Aufzug fährt und der hält dann plötzlich an. Also bei manchen Aufzügen, da kriegt man... Da geht es so richtig durch den Körper durch.
Genau, das ist genau diesen Effekt meinte ich. Also so ähnlich fühlte sich das an. Aufzug, irgendwo hatte ich das auch noch. Oder wenn man im Flugzeug ist und man ist diesen Turbulenzen ausgesetzt. Also das war glaube ich so dieser Moment, wo man so überlegt, so Gott wird mir jetzt schlecht oder nicht. Dann ist es aber auch schon wieder vorbei. Also genau das hat so diesen Übergang in das 0G charakterisiert. Man muss ein bisschen durchatmen, so geht es mir noch gut. Und dann ja, mir geht es noch gut. Und dann geht es ab in den Weltraum.
Genau, und da sie ja jetzt Erstflieger waren an diesem 18., da müssten sie jetzt mal sagen, wie sie es empfunden haben. Bei mir ist das jetzt schon so oft vorgekommen. Ich sag das dann hinterher.
Es fing ja gar nicht mit dieser 0G an, sondern die ersten beiden Flüge waren ja gar keine 0G-Parabeln. Da wird dann eine etwas plattere oder spitzere Parabel geflogen.
Die Winkel sind etwas anders bei den Parabeln, wo wir dann die Beschleunigung bekommen, wie sie auf dem Mond herrscht und wie sie auf dem Mars herrscht. Da werden dann etwas andere Winkel der Parabel, also etwas flacher Parabeln.
Das erste war glaube ich der Mars. Das ist dann 0,4.
0,38, genau.
Der normalen Erdbeschleunigung. Das heißt ungefähr so 30-40%. Das ist natürlich für den das erste Mal überhaupt eine Änderung der Schwerkraft bemerkt. Das ist natürlich erst mal der Moment. Man merkt dann, man taumelt nicht durch die Gegend, sondern man hüpft halt so ein bisschen wie so eine Comicfigur durch die Gegend. Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr merkwürdig. Das Lustigste in dem Moment ist einfach, dass alle das natürlich so lustig finden in dem Moment, dass einfach überall das Grinsen losgeht. Man schaut einfach nur noch in grinsende Gesichter. Das macht die ganze Sache dann auch sehr angenehm. Ja, und dann hat man halt wenige Sekunden eigentlich nur Zeit, weil man erst mal ein paar Sekunden gebraucht hat, um erst mal zu begreifen, was Sache ist. Und in dem Moment, wo man das dann voll auslebt, merkt man natürlich, ja, man hobst. Man wird schon noch angezogen, aber es ist wirklich, es ist einfach verstörend, schwer zu beschreiben. Bei der zweiten Parabel, dann sind es ja nur noch 0,16 g, also dann Mond, so. Da hat man natürlich dann sofort Aldrin und Armstrong im Kopf, wie die halt damals da über den Mond rübergehobst sind und kann das an dem Moment ganz gut nachvollziehen. Also da fühlt man sich wirklich wie ein Teddybär, hüpft so ein bisschen durch die Gegend, das ist irre.
Genau, genau. Also dieses Gefühl, mal haben zu können, wie die Apollo-Astronauten auf dem Mond, ist eben auch eine bestimmte Art von Erlebnis. Und man merkt natürlich, wenn man das das erste Mal erlebt, dann probiert man das so selber an. Was kann ich denn hier eigentlich machen? Wenn man schon mehrfach diese Art Parabeln geflogen ist, dann weiß man natürlich schon, was auf einen zukommt. Und dann kann man dann auch andere besondere Ereignisse ausprobieren. Zum Beispiel einarmige Liegestützen, die man vielleicht sonst als jedenfalls nicht besonders trainierter Mensch nicht so gut hinkriegt. Aber bei Mondschwerkraft ist das natürlich kein Problem. Oder man kann sogar etwas sportlichere Menschen, die können dann ein Looping springen. Das machen bei uns ja Fußballer schon mal. Aber ansonsten kann man das ja als normaler Mensch nicht so sehr. Aber wenn man das ein bisschen gut koordiniert kriegt bei einer Mondparabel, kann man das schon mal machen. Das ist jetzt einmal die lustige Seite. Aber diese Art Parabeln, also ein 0,38 g oder 0,16 g, haben einen wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund. Ich sprach vorhin ganz am Anfang ja davon, dass die Wissenschaftler gerne die Schwerkraftwirkung wegnehmen wollen, weil sie Phänomene überdeckt, weil sie Phänomene kaschiert, stört und sie gerne die pure Schwerkraftlose Situation untersuchen wollen. Das gilt für die reine Schwerlosigkeitsforschung. Aber es gibt in vielen Bereichen dann auch die Frage, wo sind Schwellenwerte, unterhalb derer ein System nicht reagiert, oberhalb derer aber ein System reagiert. Das ist auch wiederum wichtig zu wissen, um sich über den Mechanismus klar zu werden, wie wird man wegen Schwerkraft wahrgenommen von einem Fisch oder einer Pflanze oder auch dem Menschen. Also muss man eingeh, was ja auf der Erde immer existiert, unterteilen in Parts, partial, g. Und da sind eben 0,38 und 0,16 solche möglichen Unterteilungen. Vielleicht werden wir in Zukunft auch 0,7 g anbieten. Das müssen wir jetzt mal schauen. Auf jeden Fall gibt es jetzt, haben wir bereits ein erstes Mal, eine solche Parabelflugkampagne angeboten für die Wissenschaft, wo nur solche partial g Parabeln, also Mars, Mond und Schwerelosigkeit zum Vergleich angeboten wurden. Also neben diesem Erleben, was kann ich damit machen, was jetzt nicht das Wissenschaftliche hauptsächlich ist, haben wir da auch einen wissenschaftlichen Background dahinter.
Ja, bei der dritten Parabel war es dann halt 0 g. Und das war dann schon nochmal besonders erstaunlich. Ich bin erstmal gegen die Decke geknallt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das dann so eine Minus-G-Wirkung war. Das heißt, man schießt sozusagen über das... Das ist das Ziel hinaus und was ich wirklich bemerkenswert fand, ist, wie sehr, also man merkt in dem Moment dann doch sehr deutlich, was, dass man eben so ein Eingegerät ist. Ja, also der Körper ist halt einfach für diese Schwerkraft gebaut und in dem Moment, wo sie wegfällt, fällt auch ein ganz wichtiges Instrument der Bewegung des Körpers weg. Man hat ihn einfach nicht mehr unter Kontrolle. Also während man sich sonst jeglicher Mini-Bewegung extrem bewusst ist und genau weiß, was man tun muss, um das herzustellen, war das dann auf einmal weg. Man taumelt förmlich hilflos durch die Luft.
Ja, so ist das. Man muss bedenken, dass wir, ja, wir Menschen, alles Lebende, ist ja immer unter 1G-Bedingungen, also unter der Schwerkraft, die auf der Erde immer herrscht, entstanden. Wir haben uns entwickelt und wir sind daran natürlich optimal angepasst. Also unsere Sinnesorgane kommen normalerweise mit 1G, aber auch mit mehrfachen G. Das wird ja jeder Rallyefahrer oder natürlich auch, wenn man so Fahrgeschäfte auf Kirmessen ausprobiert, da gibt es ja auch mehr als 1G. Zu erdulden, erleiden oder zu erleben, wie man will oder auch die Piloten bei der Luftwaffe, die ja auch mehrere G aushalten. Also das können wir koordinieren. So und jetzt auf einmal sind wir in Schwerelosigkeit. Da sagt natürlich unser Geist und unser Körper, was ist nun los. Also das habe ich erstens noch nie erlebt und zweitens, wie überlebe ich denn jetzt? Und es ist wirklich, obwohl ich ja Naturwissenschaftlerin bin, im positiven Sinne wunderbar, dass der Mensch diese Möglichkeit tatsächlich, also die es hinkriegt, alles so zu koordinieren, dass wir uns in Kürze umstellen. Sie werden vielleicht auch festgestellt haben, am Anfang ist man ein bisschen überrascht und unkoordiniert. Manche paddeln dann so ein bisschen wild durch die Gegend, weil sie so irgendwo wollen, so was greifen. Das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie ein Fisch auf dem Trockenen. Aber das wirkt ja nicht wirklich gut, weil da kommt man nicht voran.
Genau.
Und das wird dann ganz schnell ruhiger. Nach zwei, drei Parabeln hat man kapiert, so geht es nicht. Ich muss mich einfach recht bewegungsarm verhalten, es sei denn, ich hab dann schon gelernt, dass ich mit gewissen Abstößen von der Wand dann so und so weit komme. Und wenn ich meinen Körper so und so biege und verhalte, dann kann ich ein Looping machen oder so. Also ich finde, das ist eine tolle Leistung und zeigt eben auch die Flexibilität des menschlichen Körpers, des Geistes auch, das alles völlig unbekannt zu verarbeiten und zu etwas Sinnvollem, etwas Neuem Sinnvollem zu bringen, nämlich wir können uns da ordentlich verhalten. Und die Wissenschaftler sind das beste Beispiel. Die arbeiten und machen ihre Experimente, in welcher Phase sie auch gerade sind. Die Piloten machen ihre Arbeit, sogar ohne Medikamente. Also insofern, wir sind sehr, sehr flexibel in der Reaktion auf veränderte Umwelten.
Ja, es war wirklich sehr interessant. Ich hatte auch so den Eindruck, es wird geradezu die Neugier aktiviert. Ich habe in dem Moment die Astronauten auch gleich noch mal auf eine andere Art und Weise verstanden, dass das extrem süchtig machen kann, im besten Wortsinne. Man hätte sich in dem Moment einfach mal so gewünscht, dass die Schwerelosigkeit jetzt einfach mal fünf Minuten anhält. Ich würde jetzt gerne mal eine halbe Stunde lang nur von vorne nach hinten rotationsstabilisiert wie so ein Satellit im hibernischen Modus von einer Seite zur anderen fliegen, um einfach das mal nachvollziehen zu können. Das ist natürlich so ein Spaß, den man an der ISS voll auskosten kann.
Hatten Sie eine besondere Assoziation, als das um die Schwerelosigkeit wirklich kam, mit der dritten Parabel? War da irgendwie ein besonderes Bild, ein besonderer Zustand?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Ich war auch enorm mit meinem ganzen Gerät beschäftigt, um auch alles aufzuzeichnen, was ich so gemacht hab. Ich weiß nicht genau, worauf Sie genau fallen.
Also es gibt Berichte, also den Zustand der Schwerelosigkeit erleben Menschen unterschiedlich. Das ist nicht für alle gleich. Es gibt welche, die sagen, ich stehe, ich fühle mich so, als stünde ich am Rand einer Felskante. Und sobald die Schwerelosigkeit dann begonnen hat, falle ich, ich falle ewig. Nämlich so lange, wie die Schwerelosigkeitsphase anhält. Das ist erstens ein Ideechen, was beängstigend, aber wird sofort schön. Dann gibt es welche, die können das überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen, sondern für die ist das von Anfang an nur einfach befreiend. Die riesengroße Freiheit, die Leichtigkeit. Ich selbst lasse mich dann auch schon mal wirklich treiben mit geschlossenen Augen. Bitte jemandem zu gucken, dass ich nicht irgendwo hintreibe, wo ich jemanden störe. Und auch frühzeitig muss man sich ja wieder einrichten, wenn die Parabel zu Ende geht, dass derjenige mich dann in die richtige Lage, weil mit geschlossenen Augen, ich weiß ja nicht, wo oben und unten ist, bringt. Man spürt nichts mehr, man spürt kein Gewicht, man spürt keine Arme und Hände, Arme und Beine, man spürt keinen Druck mehr auf einen, weil nicht wie im Wasser beim Tauchen, man hat ja keinen Druck auf dem Körper. Also es ist wirklich die absolut unendliche Leichtigkeit und Freiheit. Bei den ersten Parabeln, die ich geflogen bin, hatte ich das eher unangenehme Erlebnis einer Inversion-Illusion, das kriegen auch einige, nämlich dass man das Gefühl hat, alles steht auf dem Kopf, nur ich bin richtig. Ich bin richtig, aber die Welt um mich herum steht auf dem Kopf. Und das ist ja wohl ein bisschen blöd, schräg. Also darf ja wohl nicht sein. Das stört einen, ist ein bisschen beängstigend. Und das ist ein Phänomen, was auch von den Astronauten wohl bekannt ist und aber auch von Kampfflugzeugfliegern, insbesondere im Dunkeln bei Einsätzen, wo der Sternenhimmel eine gewisse Ähnlichkeit mit den Lampen auf dem Boden hat und die dann durch ihre eigenartigen Manöver, die sie da manchmal fliegen, wenn sie zum Beispiel verkehrt rumfliegen, dann auch so eine Inversion Illusion bekommen können, ist unangenehm. Vor allen Dingen fördert sie dann auch dieses unangenehme Gefühl und mögliche Kinnethose, also kann auch dann zur Übelkeit führen. Ich habe dann gelernt, wie man das überwindet und das nicht mehr kriegt und jetzt kommt es auch nicht mehr und das finde ich auch sehr gut.
Also was muss man da begreifen?
Also Astronauten sagten mir, du musst schauen, dass du so in der Lage bist, dass du die Füße an den Boden pressen kannst. Also zum Beispiel im Sitz Gurt festmachen, Füße auf den Boden pressen, weil dann kommt Druck auf die Fußsohlen und unser Geist sagt uns, naja da wo Druck ist, ist unten und normalerweise stehen wir halt auf den Füßen und dann ist wieder alles in Ordnung. Dann wird das umgeswitcht im Kopf und dann sind wir, wissen wir wieder wo oben und wo unten sind. Da stellen sich viele interessante Fragen. Da gibt es erste Experimente von Psychologen auch, die sich damit beschäftigt haben. Wie nehmen wir eigentlich die Achse unseres Körpers wahr? Haben wir ein eigenes oben und unten System und so weiter? Also interessant, hart der Bearbeitung.
Also ich hatte interessanterweise keine Probleme, das oben und unten so auseinander zu halten, obwohl ich da gewisser Hinsicht eher mit gerechnet hätte, dass sich das so auflöst. Aber so diese Basisorientierung innerhalb dieses Flugzeugs, die ist bei mir nie weggegangen. Ich kann nicht sagen, woran das lag oder ob ich jetzt vielleicht zufällig irgendwas richtig gemacht habe, was man auch hätte falsch machen können. Ja, also 22 Sekunden reichen eigentlich gar nicht aus. Das ist eigentlich so, dass das was schnell hängen bleibt. Trotzdem versucht man natürlich dann sich immer auf die nächste Parabel zu konzentrieren. Überhaupt war die ganze Phase bei mir zumindest, ich war eigentlich die ganze Zeit dauerkonzentriert. Ich habe mich eigentlich immer versucht wirklich auf jede Sekunde genau zu konzentrieren, auch da jetzt mein eigenes Wohlergehen zu fördern, dann halt auch die Ein- und die Ausflugsphasen da möglichst richtig zu begleiten. Das ist mir auch ganz gut gelungen, also zumindest ist mir nicht schlecht geworden. Ja, ich habe ja auch noch versucht, nebenbei dann die Arbeit der Wissenschaftler zu verfolgen, die ja nicht so sehr jetzt auf den eigenen Spaß und Jux und Dollerei ausgelegt sind, sondern die ja ganz emsig sich ihren Projekten gewidmet haben, die natürlich auch das Problem haben, dass sie erstmal durch die Gegend fliegen, genau in dem Moment, wo sie dann vielleicht noch irgendwas bedienen müssen. Aber die sind ja auch ganz gut vorbereitet. Es gibt ja auch so Spanngurte am Boden, mit denen man sich dann ganz gut befestigen kann. Überhaupt sind diese Spanngurte die beste Einrichtung. Interessant ist halt, wenn dann die Phase vorbei ist, wie dann auf einmal dieses Schwerkraft dann auf einmal wieder kommt. Man hat so fast das Gefühl, man wird auf den Boden gesaugt. Das setzt halt auch wieder genauso mit dieser Trägheit ein, wie sie vorher verschwunden ist. So eine Sekunde, zwei Sekunden und dann zieht es einen geradezu magnetisch nach unten. Und dieser Magnet, das ist vielleicht auch ein ganz guter Vergleich. Der Magnetismus, weil den nimmt man ja auch zusätzlich zu der Schwerkraft wahr. In dem Moment, wo man so zwei Magneten aneinander hält, die sich eben anziehen wollen und dann ja auch die Schwerkraft egalisieren. So in der Luft fliegen und so ähnlich ist es da auch. Das wird einem dann klar, wenn man auch in der Phase der doppelten Schwerkraft mal versucht, das Bein zu heben, was ja unglaublich schwer geht. Man holt das hoch und die einzige Erklärung, die mein Kopf in dem Moment hatte, ist, dass das magnetisch ist. Das war einfach meine unmittelbare Assoziation. Ich habe jetzt einen magnetischen Fuß und der Boden ist irgendwie auch magnetisch oder irgendwas ist der Magnet des Anderes. Das ist Metall und der fliegt förmlich wieder nach unten. So war das.
Ja, man sieht daran, wie sehr wir eben für ganz selbstverständlich unsere normale Umwelt nehmen, was natürlich klar ist, weil da leben wir ja drin, diese 1G herrschen halt immer. Wenn wir morgens die Zahnbürste fallen lassen, dann war das halt die Schwerkraft, die die nach unten hat fallen lassen. Und wenn im Kochtopf die Luftblasen nach oben steigen, dann tun sie das, weil sie eben leichter sind als das Wasser. Und wenn ältere Frauen vom langen Stehen dicke Beine kriegen, dann ist das eben auch eine Wirkung der Schwerkraft. Das nehmen wir überhaupt nicht konkret wahr, die dicken Beine schon, weil irgendwann muss man da vielleicht was gegen tun. Aber so ist eben unsere Umgebung. Und bei einem solchen Parabelflug, da sehen wir eben diese Wechsel und beobachten sie sehr stark. Man kann das natürlich auch auf Kirmesfahrgeschäften, kann man auch eben Wechsel von Beschleunigungen feststellen. Und das ist sicher auch ein Grund, warum einige Menschen das eben auch so gerne mal ausprobieren oder machen. Weil das eben mal andere Umgebungsbedingungen, was die Beschleunigung angeht, für uns bietet. Von allen Erzählungen, ich leite ja diese Parabelflüge seit 1999 und hab natürlich schon viele hundert Menschen getroffen von den Wissenschaftlern, die Parabelflüge geflogen sind. Insbesondere natürlich ist der Eindruck nach dem ersten Mal so ganz besonders. Alle sagen, es ist etwas völlig Unvergleichliches. Man kann es mit nichts auf dem Boden wirklich vergleichen. Und alle schildern es als etwas Großartiges. Wenn man Filmaufnahmen oder auch die Menschen so beobachtet im Parabelflieger, alle lachen ja, sind freudig. Manche sogar mit Ausrufen entsprechend. Also es ist für alle, die dabei sind, immer etwas Positives, ein schönes Erlebnis. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Psychologen sich da schon mal mit intensiver beschäftigt haben, mir nicht bekannt. Jedenfalls ist es doch eklatant, dass das von allen Mitfliegern nur immer als etwas Positives und Schönes festgestellt wird. Ich kann das natürlich selber nur unterstützen. Man wird da ja auch richtig süchtig nach.
Das kann ich mir wirklich gut vorstellen. Ich fand es auch sehr interessant, mit den Erfahrenerinnen zu sprechen. Unter anderem war ja auch die Samantha Cristoforetti mit in dem selben Flug, die ich auch schon mal über Raumzeit, vor längerer Zeit, zu ihren Erfahrungen in der Astronautenausbildung befragt habe. Die hat natürlich dann gleich ganz andere Sachen ausprobiert, mal im Kreis laufen, also die Wände hoch, was man sonst nur im Falle eines Wutanfalls erwägt. Das kann man natürlich da auch ausprobieren, um sich damit vertraut zu machen. Aber sie sagte auch, wichtig ist, gerade für ihre Arbeit, sich natürlich auch mit diesem wissenschaftlichen Prozess vertraut zu machen. Was heißt es, eine Arbeit von anderen zu begleiten? Das ist ja eigentlich das, was Astronauten im Wesentlichen tun. Und da eben auch diese Verbindung aufrechtzuerhalten.
Das machen wir eben jetzt auch gerade, wo wir ja nun ein neu ausgewähltes Astronautenteam in Europa haben, die jetzt ja sich im Training befinden und dann eben über kurz oder lang auf die Raumstation geschickt werden. Und da bieten wir auch vom DLR unsere Parabelflüge an, damit diese jungen Astronauten schon in Kontakt mit Experimenten kommen, die dann eben auch auf der ISS durchgeführt werden sollen und eben auch mit den Wissenschaftlern in Kontakt kommen. Denn man muss bedenken, die Wissenschaftler, die an einem Thema hier arbeiten, die tun das monatelang. Das ist ihr Feld, wo sie forschen. Und wenn sie ein Experiment auf der Raumstation durchgeführt haben wollen, brauchen sie dazu den verlängerten Arm Astronaut. Und andererseits, der Astronaut ist ja Mädchen für alles. Er muss sich um die Technik der Raumstation kümmern, um alles Mögliche und auch um die Wissenschaft. Und für beide Seiten ist es wichtig und schön, wenn sie auch frühzeitig hier in Kontakt kommen, um auch so die Denkweisen und die Möglichkeiten des jeweils anderen kennenzulernen. Und beim Parabelflug ist eben das Gute, das ist eben die einzige Fluggelegenheit, wo der Wissenschaftler an Bord selber arbeitet und der Astronaut ihm quasi über die Schulter gucken kann, beziehungsweise sogar schon getrainiert wird, dass er das Experiment, wie auch hier in unserem Fall von Frau Christopher Reti und Alexander Gerst, das die richtigen wissenschaftliches Experiment dann auch durchgeführt haben.
Auf jeden Fall alles sehr viel vielseitiger, als man das am Anfang vielleicht glauben mag. So ein Parabelflug hat auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge Aspekte, wie auch die ganze Schwerelosigkeitsforschung oder Forschung in der Schwerelosigkeit. Man hat trotz eingespielter Prozesse schon auch immer den Eindruck, dass da eine ganze Menge Pionierarbeit geleistet wird, dass auch wissenschaftlich einfach noch an Sachen gearbeitet wird, wo man vielleicht dachte, naja, da ist ja alles tutti, da hat man schon irgendwie alles verstanden. Da gab es dann in der Vorbereitung ja auch die Vorstellung der wissenschaftlichen Experimente, die dann mit an Bord sind, was ich finde eine sehr gute Sache hielt, um einfach mal auch zu verstehen, was da vor sich geht. Unter anderem so die Forschung an Granulaten, wo dann so einstürzende Silos gezeigt wurden mit, ja ja, also so weit sind wir noch nicht, dass wir mit Sicherheit sagen können, wie sich jetzt so ein Haufen Sand zuverlässig auch hier unten am Boden nicht nur im Weltall verhält. Und deswegen werden an der Stelle auch diese Forschung vorangetrieben, um das einfach auch besser zu verstehen.
Ja, genau so ist es. Natürlich wollen wir nicht so vermessen sein, zu sagen, dass durch ein paar Experimente auf einem Parabelflug wir jetzt in Zukunft lösen können, dass so ein Silo mit Getreide nicht mehr explodiert. Aber das sind einfach kleine Schrittchen. Solche Unglücke passieren, weil man eben das Verhalten, zum Beispiel von Granulaten, einfach noch nicht voll durchdrungen hat und nicht versteht. Natürlich sind das Fragen, die hier auf der Erde anstehen und kräftig geforscht werden. Und der Aspekt, dort in Schwerelosigkeit gewisse Phänomene zu untersuchen, ist immer nur ein Teil von diesem ganzen Forschungsbereich. Und in verschiedenen Bereichen wurde schon in der Vergangenheit gezeigt, dass meinetwegen eine Nobelpreishypothese, also wo jemand den Nobelpreis für bekommen hat, dass die einfach nicht richtig war. Weil dieser Mensch zu der Zeit das nicht in Schwerelosigkeit hat überprüfen können. Es gibt auch Beispiele, wo eben schon durch Forschung in Schwerelosigkeit, zum Beispiel im medizinischen Bereich, das dann schon in die klinische Anwendung auch rübergeht. Die Kenntnis natürlich wird man den Patienten nicht in Schwerelosigkeit bringen. Aber die Grundkenntnisse, wie verläuft die Atmung genau, das kann helfen, auch auf der Erde gewisse, in diesem Fall eine Therapie oder Behandlung zu optimieren. Das sind immer wieder auch unsere Erfahrungen. Letztendlich ist einfach diese Forschung eine Basis für weitere Forschung morgen oder auch Überanwendung übermorgen. Forschung hat einen langen Vorlauf, aber wir als Deutschland, als ein Land mit wenig Rohstoffen, unsere Basis liegt eben in unseren Köpfen, unser Wissen, unsere Kenntnisse und der Bereich in der Raumfahrtforschung, auch in Schwerelosigkeit, ist eben ein Teilaspekt daraus.
Nach meinem Parabelflug haben mich natürlich alle gefragt, wo kann ich mich anstellen? Ich will jetzt auch mit. Das ist natürlich eine Gelegenheit, die sich jetzt so immer nur wenigen bietet. Wie ist das so mit Nichtwissenschaftlern und den Parabelflügen? Welche Möglichkeiten der Beteiligung gibt es?
Bei unseren Parabelflügen, die wir mit diesem Testflugzeug machen, das sind wirklich rein wissenschaftliche Parabelflüge. Dieses Flugzeug ist auch für Passagierflüge noch nicht zugelassen. Da wird dran gearbeitet, aber bisher kann man da nur als Experimentator an Bord. Es gibt weltweit Veranstalter, das kann man die Information im Internet finden, wo man auch als normaler Tourist, als normaler Mensch, solche Flüge mitfliegen kann, das gibt es in den USA, das gibt es in Moskau. Sie sind nicht billig, aber man muss einfach auch sagen, dass diese Flüge für sich nicht billig sind. Man muss ein extrem gut gewartetes Flugzeug haben, man muss unterstützendes Team haben, man muss exzellente Piloten haben. Das kostet halt ein bisschen mehr, als mal nach Mallorca zu fliegen. Aber es ist bezahlbar. Das kann man sich zusammensparen.
Also 6.000, 7.000 Euro oder so was in einer Größenordnung.
Genau, und jetzt so 4.000 Dollar in den USA. Da muss man natürlich noch hinkommen und so weiter. Also in dem Bereich bewegt sich das. Ich kann es jedem nur empfehlen, der jetzt nicht ein wenig Flugangst hat. Da wäre das nicht ganz richtig. Aber das Erlebnis ist so unvergleichlich. Das Erlebnis Schwerelosigkeit ist so etwas Tolles, dass ich das eigentlich jedem Menschen wünschen würde.
Gab es noch mal künstlerische Experimente im Rahmen eines Parabelflugs?
Ja, wir hatten mal einen zehnten Parabelflug gehabt. Und das ist ja dann ein kleines Jubiläum. Das sollte man feiern. Und da hat das DLR sich auch erinnert, dass es auch eine gewisse Verpflichtung in dem künstlerischen Bereich hat. Und wir haben zwei Experimente an Bord genommen, die eine Verknüpfung zwischen Wissenschaft und Kunst darstellten. Also man hat die quasi wissenschaftliche Beobachtung. Die Beobachtung von Phänomenen, wie sie nur in Schwerelosigkeit auftreten können. In diesem Fall zum Beispiel das Verhalten von Flüssigkeit in Schwerelosigkeit. Es gibt Wahnsinnsbilder dadurch. Und dann ist es natürlich auch die Aufgabe von Künstlern, solche Beobachtung dermaßen umzusetzen und zu präsentieren, dass eben auch dieser künstlerische Aspekt da zum Tragen kommt. Und das ist über viele Ausstellungen zu sehen gewesen. Und ich denke, der Ansatz war ganz gut gelungen. Und sowas ist auch wieder für das nächste Jahr oder nächste Jahre gelegentlich mal geplant.
Da kommt dann ein 20. und ein 25. Flug. Das lädt ja schon mal ein. Da kann sich die Kunstwelt ja auch schon mal Gedanken machen, mit welchem Vorschlag sie da aufläuft. Ja, ich glaube, jetzt haben wir es aber auch wirklich die Parabel komplett geflogen. Vielen, vielen Dank für die ausführlichen Ausführungen zu Forschung und Schwerelosigkeit. Ulrike Friedrich, gibt es noch einen letzten Wunsch, einen letzten Aspekt, den wir ausgelassen haben?
Ich glaube nicht. Wir haben wirklich ein sehr interessantes Gespräch geführt. Mich hat auch gefreut, einen Interviewpartner zu haben, der selber weiß, was Schwerelosigkeit ist und bedeutet. Und dass nicht nur ich sage, wie wunderbar dieses Erlebnis ist, sondern zumindest von Ihnen auch hier bestätigt bekommen habe.
Kann ich auf jeden Fall bestätigen.
Und dass letztendlich neben diesem Erleben es auch für die Wissenschaftler, für die wir das ja nun hier veranstalten, ist ja der wissenschaftliche Aspekt im Vordergrund. Aber das Erleben kommt eben mit dabei. Und jeder, der auf Parabelflügen in Schwerelosigkeit experimentiert, hat halt das Erlebnis Schwerelosigkeit gratis mit dabei.
Und wie immer auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Heute mal wieder eine besonders ausführliche, aber ich denke auch ausgesprochen lohnenswerte Episode von Raumzeit. Aber damit sind wir natürlich nicht am Ende. Hier geht es bald wieder weiter mit weiteren interessanten Themen. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.